REVIEW WILL COME TO ORDER- WE I
WILL. GIVE US OUR PROFESSION
COMMENTS THOUGH WE WILL.
POTENTIALLY START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE THERE ARE
A LOT OF OTHER COMMITTEES UNDER
WAY AT THE SAME TIME AND IT MAY
BE AWHILE BEFORE WE CAN
ESTABLISH QUORUM BUT SERIOUS
THERE ARE ENOUGH PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM WE WILL. BUT FOR NOW LET
ME JUST SAY THAT- AS WE OPEN
EVERY COMMITTEE WITH NOW DUE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT ALL OF US WE ARE
LIMITING NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND ADHERING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINE GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE ADJUSTMENTS
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING THE HEARING. HERE
TODAY IN THE CAPITAL. THEN
HOWEVER OUR REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE LEGEND OF THIS OFFICE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND OTHERS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND THE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS I KNOW YOU
KNOW WHAT TO DO- PLEASE USE THE
POP UP WINDOW IF YOU WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED. AND YOU WILL HIT ON
MUTE TO BEGIN SPEAKING THEN OUR
I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE. WHEN YOU'RE DONE.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS HERE
THERE'S THIS MAIN ONE IN AN
EXHILARATING RUN AND WILL ALSO
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO USE THE
TELECONFERENCE. THE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE ONE SEVEN.
EIGHT THREE THREE SIX. AND IF
YOU'VE NOT USED THIS SYSTEM
BEFORE YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
SENATE OR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS. NOW THOSE OF YOU
WHO USE A TELECONFERENCE PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU MUTE THE DEVICE
THAT YOU ARE LISTENING TO THIS
HEARING ON BEFORE YOU GIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY OTHERWISE WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU VERY WELL. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE SERVICE OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES AND SUCH DUE TO THE
TECHNO TECHNOLOGY TOOLS. SO
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD- LET'S SEE AM I ANYWHERE
NEAR A QUORUM. THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN AND- THE- DOESN'T
WANT TO- MAYBE I'M GETTING
CLOSER. BECAUSE ONE SECOND WHAT
IS- OKAY WE'RE ALMOST STATIC
WE'RE GOT EIGHT NOT TEN BUT- SO
I'M NOT GONNA ASK THE ARKANSAS
MISTER STEPPING CHART TO-
DETERMINE QUORUM YET BECAUSE I
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE IT SO WE'RE
INSTEAD GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. AND LET ME LAY
OUT WHAT WE ARE DOING. WE THIS
IS OUR SECOND HEARING ON
TRAILER BILLS THAT ARE PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PACKAGE WE HAVE
ELEVEN TRAILER BILLS UP BEFORE
US TODAY THEY ENACT STATUTORY
CHANGES THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET IN THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AREA LABOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND SMALL
BUSINESS SUPPORT AND CANNABIS
THE BILLS WE'RE HEARING TODAY
WILL BE ON THE SENATE FLOOR
TOMORROW ASSUMING THAT THEY
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AND THEN AFTER
TODAY WE EXPECT TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILLS NEXT
WEEK- AND THE WEEK AFTER. AS WE
KNOW THIS WAS A MONUMENTAL
BUDGET THE LARGEST-
EXPENDITURES OF GENERAL FUND
THEN THE LARGEST RESERVE AND
THE LARGEST- REVENUES ABOVE
WHAT WE HAD PROJECTED IN STATE
HISTORY. SO A LOT OF WORK HAS
GONE INTO IT AND OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE DETAILS
OF THE TRAILER BILLS ARE RIGHT
SO THAT'S WHY IT MAY TAKE SOME
TIME- OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS TO GET THEM ALL. SO TODAY
WE ARE. THE BILLS THAT ARE
BEFORE US THE ELEVEN. AND THEN
WE WILL HAVE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ALL OF THOSE BILLS
FOLLOWING IT AND AFTER THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL VOTE ON
THE BILLS. MR VICE CHAIR DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. OKAY AS
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON FIVE
OF COURSE OBVIOUSLY AT ANY
POINT AND HE SAYS THE BILLS ARE
BEING HEARD WE CERTAINLY
WELCOME YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND
READ- QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT SO
LET ME BEGIN FIRST. WITH THE
PRESENTATION ON AB ONE THIRTY
pSERVICES ACT AND LET ME ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK
IT'S ERICA LEVY THAT WILL BE
JOINING US TO- COULD YOU
PRESENT. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
ERICA LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- THIS IS THE FIRST
OF ELEVEN TRAILER BILLS AT ONE
THIRTY FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT AND THIS BILL
MAKES AN APPROPRIATION OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE. ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX POINT
NINETY SEVEN MILLION FROM THE
FEDERAL TRUST FUND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IT
EXTENDS ATHORIZATION TO THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR THAT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. TO
ALLOW COMPANIES TO DETERMINE
THE PERCENTAGE OF FUNDS TO
ALLOCATE ACROSS PROGRAMS FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS AND OLDER
ADULTS BY MEANS OF ALL COUNTY
LETTERS OR OTHER SIMILAR
INSTRUCTIONS WITHOUT TAKING
FURTHER REGULATORY ACTION. IT
AUTHORIZES A COUNTY THAT IS
UNABLE TO SUBMIT A THREE YEAR
PLAN OUR ANNUAL UPDATE FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL
YEAR DUE TO THE KOBE NINETEEN.
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY TO
EXTEND TO THE EFFECTIVE TIME
FRAME OF ITS OF ITS CURRENT
CURRENTLY APPROVED THREE YEAR
PLAN OR ANNUAL UPDATE. AND THEN
SUBMIT A PLAN TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- AND THOSE ARE THE
HIGHLIGHTS FOR EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT LET'S
SEE IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE- FEDERAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT TRAILER BILL
BEFORE US. ALL RIGHT SCENE
NINE- THEN I WILL GO TO THE
NEXT TRAILER BILL AND ALLOWED
OF FINANCE TO PRESENT ON AB ONE
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS GENERAL
GOVERNMENT. GO AHEAD THE
MANAGER WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
PRINT ON EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX
FIRST OF ALL I'M SORRY ARE YOU
WHEN MY EYES JUMPED ONE OF THEM
NOW OKAY YOU'RE RIGHT WE SHOWED
YOU WANT THIRTY SIX FIRST WHICH
IS THE TRAILER BILL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THAT'S
RIGHT OKAY EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
SIX- DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
THIS BILL INCLUDES EIGHTY NINE
POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FINDS BEGIN THE BASIN OF
INCREASED RATES WITHIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- IT ALSO
GIVES DIRECTOR DISCRETION TO RE
AUTHORIZE. PLACEMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGHLY
SPECIALIZED NEEDS AN OUT OF
STATE FACILITIES. IS LONGER
THAN SIX MONTHS. ELIMINATES THE
PROVIDER EXPANSIONS AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE UNIFORMS
HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. IT INCLUDES
TWENTY THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
REGIONAL CENTER OPERATIONS AS
WELL AS PURCHASE THAT SERVICES
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ELIGIBILITY
FOR CHILDREN AGED THREE AND
FOUR. UNDER THE LAW ALSO
INCLUDES FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION I'M GOING BEGINNING IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ZERO TO
IMPLEMENT A TIERED TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS-
TEND TO WAGE DIFFERENTIALS. IT
ALSO INCLUDES TEN POINT THREE
MILLION TO IMPROVE ONBOARDING
INTO THE SELF DETERMINANTS
PROGRAM. AND FINALLY INCREASE
IT INCLUDES SIXTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION FOR REGIONAL CENTERS TO
ADMINISTER AN ENHANCED LANGUAGE
ACCESS AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
INITIATIVES. INCLUDING FOR
TRANSLATIONS OF ORIENTATIONS
AND TRAININGS TO MEET LANGUAGE
NEEDS OFTHE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS ON.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO A REQUEST. THANK YOU
I ACTUALLY DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS- FIRST I WANTED TO
INDICATE THAT I WAS REALLY
HAPPY TO SEE. THE IN THIS BILL
THE ITEM AROUND THE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
OUR REGIONAL CENTERS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY A CALIFORNIA BEING
THE DIVERSE STATE WE ARE. WE
HAVE FOLKS WHO NEED THOSE
SERVICES WHO DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE ENGLISH AS THEIR FIRST
LANGUAGE. OR ALSO HAVE- MAY
APPROACH JUST DID. THE CULTURAL
ORIENTATIONS VERY DIFFERENT
ADDITIONALLY SO I WOULD
PRESUMABLY TO SEE THAT. THE
OTHER THING THAT I AM- WELL
COMMON AT LATER BUT ON THE- I
WAS IN THE LEGISLATURE DURING
THE RECESSION WHEN WE CUT. THE
RATES TO PROVIDERS OF THESE
SERVICES UP FOR ARE TOO BAD RGD
SERVICES AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SEE THAT WE ARE MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF RESTORING KNOWS
AND WHAT I'D LIKE IF YOU DON'T
MIND WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER IS
WHAT- WHAT DOES THIS MEAN IN
THE FIRST YEAR- IN OTHER WORDS
I KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE PHASED
IN OVER TIME BUT IS THERE A
CERTAIN PERCENT THAT WILL BE
INCREASED IN THIS FIRST YEAR.
I'M SURE I'LL I'LL START WITH
THAT QUESTION AND THEN A LOT OF
IT OVER TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
DETAILS BUT THE INITIAL FIRST
YEAR IS EIGHTY NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION AND IT DOES GROW. TO
ONE POINT TWO MILLION- IN THE
FIFTH YEAR THOSE ARE THAT'S THE
RANGE BUT I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR
MORE DETAILS. THANK YOU. HI
CHRIS O'NEILL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- I'M SURE. ON SO THE
WAY THAT THAT THE- THE RIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION IS STRUCTURED-
RATES WOULD INCREASE BY 25% OF
WHAT THE RACY MODELS HAVE SAID
THAT CERTAIN SERVICE CODES-
SHOULD SHOULD BE ADVANCING
TWENTY NINETEEN NUMBER SO THERE
WOULD BE AN INCREMENTAL
INCREASE. BY 25% BEGINNING
APRIL FIRST ON THE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION- INTO BUDGET
YEAR IS PRIMARILY DUE TO
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT TO WORK
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AT
THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES- ON APPROVAL
OF THAT PLAN AND ALSO THE
OPERATIONALIZED INCREASES TO
REGIONAL CENTRES. CONTINUING TO
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE TO TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE WOULD BE THAT
25% INCREASE. IN TWO YEARS AND
THEN FOR THE FOLLOWING- FISCAL
YEARS AND BE A 50% INCREASE IN
YOUR 525-220-2520 TWENTY SIX-
WOULD BE FULL FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION AND- AT THAT
POINT IT WOULD BE 90% BASE PAY
FOR- FOR PROVIDERS BASED ON THE
RATE MODELS AND TEN PERCENT. UP
210% COULD BE EARNED BASED ON A
QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM DIED-
IS GOING TO BE DEVELOPED DURING
THIS UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR AND
IN THE INTERVENING YEARS FOR
THAT QUALITY INCENTIVE PROGRAM
THERE ALSO BE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO- TO FIND A QUALITY
INCENTIVES. THANK YOU AND- I
HOPE THAT WE CAN HI. THIS IS-
IS THAT WE CAN GET TO THE POINT
WHERE I HOPE THAT OUR REVENUES
ARE SUCH THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THE- THE FULL RATE SIDE
UNDER IDENTIFIED UNDER THE RATE
STUDY PRIOR TO THE- TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE YEAR- BUT OF COURSE
WE'LL SEE THAT OVER TIME BUT
I'M GLAD TO SEE THIS PROGRESS
BEING MADE. LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS AND THEN I'M IN A
CALL FOR QUORUM A YES SENATOR
EDMUND. I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
COMMENT THAT THIS IS A THIS
THIS PORTION ESPECIALLY I THINK
IT'S BEEN VERY HARD FOUGHT AND
I JUST WANTED. BUT THE NOTICE
ALL THE- THE ADVOCATES AND
EVERYONE WHO REALLY CAME
TOGETHER FOR THIS IS AN AREA
THAT HAS BEEN OVERLOOKED FOR A
LONGTIME AS YOU SAID THE CUTS
WERE MADE WAY BACK THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN RESTORED AND THIS IS A
FACT THE COMMUNITY THAT YOU
KNOW THAT DEFINITELY NEEDS OUR
HELP AND IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND SO I'M JUST
SO PLEASED TO SEE THAT WHERE WE
ARE WE ARE FULFILLING OUR
PROMISE AND OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AND OBLIGATION. TO FOLKS. GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR EKMAN- LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM. A MISTER
SECOND CHART CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS SKINNER SKINNER
HERE NELSON NOTHING HERE
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT HERE
COURTESY. COURTESY HERE DOLLY
DOLLY HERE TO RAZA EGGMAN
EGGMAN HERE GROWTH. UNLOCKER
LAYERED MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MAN
MAN HERE NEWMAN NEWMAN HERE A
TOWBOAT TROUBLE HERE PM TURN BY
COUNTY MAKOWSKI HERE. SO THAT
GIVES US SAID THERE'S AT LEAST
TEN PEOPLE HERE SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM AND WE CAN CONTINUE LET
ME JUST SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE WELL THEN NOW
WE WILL GO TO. THE GENERAL
GOVERNMENT EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN TO GO HEAD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN STATE
GOVERNMENT AMENDS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SCHOOL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAM TO ADD AS AN
ELIGIBLE ENTITY A REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL CENTER THAT IS
OPERATED BY A GPA OR JOINT
POWERS DISTANCE OF FORTY- AND
THAT HAS AN ACTIVE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN PROVIDES THE STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK FOR A PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO INCENT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NEW MULTI
FAMILY AND SINGLE FAMILY MARKET
RATE RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS AS
ALL ELECTRIC BUILDINGS WERE
WITH ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS.
THE BILL ALSO ADDRESSES A
COUNTY ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD
DEADLINE SO CURRENTLY- UNDER
UNDER CURRENT LAW- IT PROVIDES
TWENTY SEVEN APPEALS BOARD'S
TWO YEARS TO. TWO YEARS TO HEAR
APPEALS FROM PROPERTY OWNERS
CHALLENGING TO THEIR PROPERTY'S
ASSESSED VALUE. I'M AT ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PROVIDES AN
EXTENSION UNTIL DECEMBER OF
THIS YEAR FOR ALL COUNTY
ASSESSMENT APPEALS. THAT WOULD
HIT THE TWO YEAR DEADLINE
BETWEEN MARCH FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY AND DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST OF. TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN ADS-
THE GOVERNMENT CODE WHICH
SPECIFIES THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IN
MANAGING THE STATE'S
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. ALLOWS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
SERVICES TO CONTRACT FOR THE
USE OF A PROGRESSIVE DESIGN
BUILD PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD
FOR NO MORE THAN THREE STATE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS. AND
AMENDS THE BUY CLEAN CALIFORNIA
ACT WHICH WAS ENACTED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TARGET CARBON
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
MANUFACTURING OF MATERIALS.
USED IN PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS-
THOSE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM.
THE BILL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. ALL RIGHT LET ME
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THIS BILL BEFORE AS A B.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
VERY STATUTE CHANGES FOR THE-
GENERAL GOVERNMENT PROVISIONS.
R. RIGHT I SEE. NINE- THE WILD
IN THAT THE- ENERGY EFFICIENCY
FUND FOR THE SCHOOLS. IS VERY
IMPORTANT IT'S MADE HUGE
IMPROVEMENTS IT IT'S
CHARACTERIZES EFFICIENCY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY HOWEVER. IT'S
RESULTED IN UPGRADES TO VERY
OLD AND FAULTY H. FAX SYSTEMS
IT'S REPAIRED WINDOWS IT'S DONE
ALL KINDS OF THINGS TO MAKE OUR
SCHOOLS A MUCH MORE IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LEARNING IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THAT THAT FUND
WAS FUNDED BY AN INITIATIVE FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND THEN-
THE FUND THE MONIES WERE RE
DIRECTED LEGITIMATELY CAUSING
MISCHIEF WAS ONLY WRITTEN A
CERTAIN WAY- BUT HOWEVER WE'RE
NOW USING THESE- STIMULUS
MONIES TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM
SO I THINK IT'S VERY VERY GOOD
AND APPRECIAE IT. AND- AND
WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS. AB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT AND THAT IS ON-
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS- IN ITS
VARIOUS STATUTE CHANGES TO OUR
LABOR AND EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
PROVISIONS GO AHEAD DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THAT'S ACTUALLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
ON AB ONE THIRTY EIGHT
EMPLOYMENT HEALTH CARE BENEFITS
I'M AT ONE THIRTY EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A GARMENT WORKER
WAGE CLAIM PILOT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
ORGANIZATIONS OF EXPERIENCE
ASSISTING GARMENT WORKERS SUCH
AS LEGAL AID CENTERS OR
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFITS TO
EXPAND OPERATIONS IN EDUCATING
GARMENT WORKERS. OF THEIR
RIGHTS AND ASSIST GOVERNMENT
WORKER WORK WORK WORKERS TO
FILE WAGE CLAIMS. EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT REQUIRES THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT- EDT TO OFFER
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE PROGRAM
SERVICES AND THE TOP EIGHT TO
FIFTEEN ADDITIONAL OR NON
PRIMARY LANGUAGES. USED BY
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA- ACCORDING
TO THE MOST RECENT CENSUS.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY ALSO REQUIRES
YOU NEED TO PROVIDE A FRAUD
PREVENTION AND DETECTION PLAN
ASSESSING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
ITS FRAUD PREVENTION AND
DETECTION AND DETECTION TOOLS
BY MAY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
BUDGET BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WITH AN UPDATE ON
ED'S PROGRESS PERFORMING
ASSESSMENT. IT ALSO REQUIRES
EACH PROVIDING DIRECT DEPOSIT
OPTION FOR ITS BENEFIT PROGRAMS
IN ADDITION TO THE OPTIONS
CURRENTLY PROVIDED SUCH AS
DEBIT CARDS AND PAPER CHECKS.
AND EXTENDS THE INCREASED-
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE WAGE
REPLACEMENT RATE ENACTED BY
EIGHTY NINE OH EIGHT FROM
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. I'M AT ONE THIRTY EIGHT
AMENDS THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
MEDICAL AND HOSPITAL CARE ACT
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES
DEPARTMENTS TO OBTAIN VERIFYING
DOCUMENTATION TO SUBSTANTIATE
CONTINUED ELIGIBILITY. AT LEAST
WHAT AT LEAST ONCE WITHIN A
THREE YEAR PERIOD FROM THE
INITIAL ENROLLMENT FOR BIRTH
AND ADOPTED CHILDREN AT LEAST
ONCE EVERY THREE YEARS FOR STEP
CHILDREN AND DOMESTIC. PARTNER
CHILDREN. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
EIGHT APPROPRIATES ONE POINT
EIGHT ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION. TWO DEBT
REPAYMENT FUNDING TO FURTHER
REDUCE THE UNFUNDED LIABILITIES
OF THE CALPERS STATE PLANS. AND
INAPPROPRIATE SIX HUNDRED
SIXTEEN MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND ON BEHALF OF
EMPLOYEES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE EMPLOYEE PRE FUNDING
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE
SUSPENDED PURSUANT TO THAT
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET AXE. AND
THOSE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM-
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY. THANK YOU AN
APARTMENT FINANCE HI. NOTE THAT
SENATOR DRAWS SO IT'S NOT HERE
AND BUT I'M SURE SHE WOULD BE
COMMENTING ON WHAT SHE SHOULD
AND THAT THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS IS DEFINED HERE IN
THIS T. B. L. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT SHE AND OTHERS- WERE VERY
STRONG ADVOCATES FOR. SO HAPPY
TO SEE THAT LET ME SEE IF ANY
OF MY- MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS EITHER FOR D. O. F.
OR L. A. O. ON THIS BILL. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT
ONE. AND THAT IS EIGHTY ONE
FORTY ONE AND IT IS THE DEPART
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. GO AHEAD FORTY FIVE
YES THANK YOU ERIC LEAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- EIGHTY
ONE FORTY ONE I TESTED- TO
SIMPLIFY PARTICIPATION IN THE
LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET AND
SUPPORT THE SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE
OPERATION OF CANNABIS
BUSINESSES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION SPCIAL FIND BAND SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR POSITIONS
TO CONSOLIDATE THE FUNCTIONS
AND POSITIONS AT THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INTO A NEW STANDALONE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
WITHIN. THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY
BEGINNING JULY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THAT THIS TRAILER
BILL REFLECTS THE AGREEMENT TO
EFFECTUATE THE CONSOLIDATION
THE CONSOLIDATION OF THESE
POSITIONS AND LICENSING
FUNCTIONS- IT ALSO INCLUDES
COMPONENTS THAT ADDRESS
PROVISIONAL LICENSES- AND THOSE
TIMELINES EMERGENCY REGULATION
AUTHORITY AND TRADE SAMPLES
AMONG OTHER ISSUES- I AM JOINED
BY SEVERAL COLLEAGUES FROM THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL FOOD
AND AG AS WELL AS PUBLIC HEALTH
TO RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS.
THE COMMITTEE HOUSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LET ME SEE YES
SENATOR CAFIERO GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- LET ME JUST
SAY THAT I REALLY AM- TORN BY
THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET TRAILER
BILL AND- AND I AND I JUST FEEL
COMPELLED TO MAKE A COMMENT
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THE PROVISIONAL THE EXTENSION
OF THE PROVISIONAL LICENSES.
NOW FOR CANNABIS- FOR A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME-
THEY EXPIRE THIS YEAR AND SO
IT'S URGENT THAT WE DO
SOMETHING IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING THE
LEGALIZATION OF MARIJUANA THAT
WE DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
SUPPORT THOSE WHO HAVE MOVED
INTO THE REGULATED MARKET THEY
ARE BUSINESSES AND WE NEED TO
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL GIVEN THAT. THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH A- A
VERY NECESSARY BUT TIME
CONSUMING CYCLIC PROCESS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE WERE NOT
PREPARED. TO UNDERTAKE ON THEIR
BEHALF THEY'RE THE PROPONENTS
OF THE- OF THE PROJECTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ISN'T SO WHILE I
SUPPORT TO THE- THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW-
CANNABIS. ENTITY AND PUT N. THE
CONSOLIDATION OF ALL THE
SERVICES INTO ONE I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD MOVE THAT
THE TREATMENT OF THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE LICENSES
HAS ME GRAVELY CONCERNED
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT IT'S
GOING TO DO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IT I AM HEARING FROM. THE
CANNABIS PRODUCERS AND- WELL
THAT CANNABIS LICENSEES THAT
HAVE PROVISIONAL LICENSE 80% OF
THE LICENSES ARE PROVISION ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M
HEARING FROM THEM AND I'M
HEARING FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THERE'S SOME SERIOUS
CHALLENGES. WITH THE WITH THE
BILL AS IT'S- AS IT'S PROPOSED
I WON'T BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY-
FOR THOSE REASONS AND I'M I'M
HOPING THAT THERE'S A SOLUTION
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE TO THAT.
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO GET THOSE SYKORA. ANALYSIS
COMPLETED ON TIME IN THAT WE
DON'T. DETRIMENTALLY PREJUDICED
THE- CURRENT PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES WHO ARE REALLY
ATTEMPTING TO ENTER THE LEGAL
MARKET AND TO STAY IN THE LEGAL
MARKET. I'M EITHER DEPARTMENT
FINANCE OR- MISS- HARBISON DID
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY COMMENT.
YES THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
AND THANK YOU SENATOR COPIER
FOR YOUR COMMENTS KIMBERLY
HARBISON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP ON
CANNABIS- GENERALLY AND
ESPECIALLY WITH PROVISIONAL
LICENSING. I DID WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT WE HAVE INCLUDED A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANT FUNDING. IN THE BUDGET TO
HELP THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
MEET THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
TIMELINE- THIS LANGUAGE ISN'T
PERFECT BUT IT REPRESENTS AN
AGREEMENT THAT WORKS AS WELL AS
WE COULD GET IT TO THIS POINT
WE'RE OPEN TO CONVERSATIONS AT
THE LEGISLATURE. TO CONTINUE
REFINING IT BUT- JUST ANOTHER
PLUG FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO BE
ESTABLISHED TOMORROW THANK YOU.
LET E SEE IF THERE'S US
SENATOR MCGUIRE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR IN IN
MEMBERS- GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL AND FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WANNA SAY HOW
GRATEFUL I AM FOR OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SALINAS FOR ALL OF HER
WORK ON THE ISSUE OF CANNABIS
AND KNOW THAT. THERE NEEDS TO
BE A LOT OF WORK. TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST THOSE WHO ARE WORKING
WITHIN HER REGION I'M NOT A
CHAIR WHEN PROP TWO SIXTEEN
PASS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT
JUST BE CANDID WITH EACH OTHER
THERE IS SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES AND WE
HAVE SPENT THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS. THAT CLEANING UP SOME OF
THE GAPS IN WHILE THERE WERE
GREAT INTENTIONS AT THE TIME
LINES CANDIDLY THE TIME LINES
THAT WERE TOO OPTIMISTIC TOO
AGGRESSIVE STATE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE LEGACY GROWERS
IN THE STATE SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS ESPECIALLY THOSE ON THE
NORTH COAST HAVE. HAD TO TRY TO
MEET IMPOSSIBLE DEADLINES TO
GET THAT LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET
OFF THE GROUND. AND AGAIN I
CANNOT STRESS THIS ENOUGH AT
THE TIME LINES WERE SIMPLY TOO
AGGRESSIVE FOR SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS TO BE ABLE DO CHEAP
THIS WE'VE LITERALLY SPENT THE
LAST FIVE YEARS TRYING TO BRING
ADDITIONAL SMALL FAMILY FARMERS
INTO THE LIGHT IN IN THE
COMPLIANCE WITH SEQUEL IN TO
BECOME GOOD PARTNERS WHICH THEY
ALL WANT TO DO. WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT GROWERS ON THE
NORTH COAST SMALL FAMILY
FARMERSWANT TO HAVE ANNUAL
LICENSES IN THE SEQUEL A INTO
B. C. QUA COMPLIANT BUT THE
PROCESS FOR EXISTING FARMERS TO
COME OUT OF THE ILLICIT MARKET.
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
CHALLENGING AND OVERLY
BURDENSOME AND BY THE WAY WE DO
NOT DO THIS FOR ANY OTHER
AGRICULTURAL CROP HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE WE DON'T DO IT FOR
TOMATOES WE DON'T DO IT FOR
GREAT SIN WE DON'T DO IT FOR
SPARE KEYS. WHILE WE'VE CREATED
A PROVISIONAL PROCESS SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WHEN EXTENDED IT A
FEW TIMES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DON'T HAVE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO GET THESE LEGACY
FARMERS. THROUGH SEE WHAT NOW
WE HAVE APPROVED THE HIGH
MILLION TO HELP LOCALS WITH
SEQUEL COMPLIANCE. WHICH IS
FANTASTIC BUT BECAUSE IT'S SO
LATE IN THE PROCESS THERE
REMAINS CHALLENGES- IN WHILE WE
WORK TO BRING THESE LEGACY
FARMERS IN. PARTICULARLY ON THE
NORTH COAST INTO COMPLIANCE AND
GET THEM THEIR ANNUAL LICENSES
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
DO NOT FALL OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WHILE WE WORK THROUGH SUN
SETTING. THE PROVISIONALS IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX AS THIS BILL
PROPOSES. SO IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS A
COMMITMENT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE THAT CERTAIN
PROVISIONS IN THE TRAILER BILL
WILL BE CLEANED UP IN THE
COMING WEEKS- THAT WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
CHEER SKINNER. SKINNER REALLY
HAS BEEN LEADING THIS EFFORT
AND I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF BETTER
BUDGETARY. HERE'S WHERE MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AMENDMENTS WILL CLARIFY IN THE
COMING WEEKS NUMBER ONE. CLEAR
FIND THAT THE EXISTING
PROVISIONS THAT WILL HAVE UNTIL
JULY FIRST. THEY WILL HAVE
UNTIL JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO COMPLETE THEIR FINAL
LAKE STREAMBED ALTERATION
AGREEMENT IN ORDER TO GET THE
PROVISIONALS RENEWED. NUMBER
TWO. CLARIFYING THAT THE
PROCESS DEMONSTRATES ETHICAL
COMPLIANCE FOR RENEWALS AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND IT'LL
BE RECOGNIZED EXISTING LOCAL
PROCESSES APPROVED BY THE STATE
TODAY THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
INVASION WITHIN A B. N. S. C.
ONE FORTY ONE. THIS INCLUDES
COUNTIES LIKE MENDOCINO IN
THEIR APPROVED CHECKLIST
PROCESS IN FINALLY MADAM CHAIR
NOT DELAY THE DEADLINE IT WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. ESTABLISHED
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WITH AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ARE. COMMITTED
TO THESE CLEANER PROVISIONS AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AT THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SALINAS-
GONNA BE SUPPORTING A B. ONE
FORTY ONE TODAY. PROP SIXTY
FOUR REQUIRED TO STATE AND
LOCAL TO LITERALLY BUILD THE
PLANE WHILE WE'RE FLYING IT.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SMALL FAMILY FARMERS TRYING
TO GET INTO THE ANNUAL LICENSE
PROGRAM CAN DO SO WHILE ALSO
RESPECTING ALL ISSUES WITH THE
ENVIRONMENT- AND REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK AND WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T
FALL OUT OF THE SYSTEM. AND
WOULD HOPE THAT WE CAN SUPPORT
THIS WITH THESE UPCOMING
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE- IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE.
DISCUSSIONS ARE UNDER WAY AND
THAT THERE. IS WORK BEING DONE
NOW TO GET LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF THE SMALL
FARMERS AND THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES. AND I WILL CALL ON
SENATOR KABIR- BUT THEN I WOULD
ALSO SEE WHETHER. ANY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION REPRESENTATIVES
WANT TO COMMENT GO AHEAD
SENATOR CAFIERO BY PROBABLY
SHOULD WAIT TO LISTEN TO THE
ADMINISTRATION I GUESS PART OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE IS
ARE AND I WANT TO. THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT- WE USUALLY
DON'T DO COMPLICATED SECRET
TYPE OF. OF CHECK CHANGES- KIND
OF ON THE FLY. AND I HAVE A
LIST LIKE I SAID I'M I'M
HEARING FROM MY LOCALS AND I'M
HEARING FROM FROM THE COUNTY-
I'M IN AND NOT VOTE TODAY
RATHER THAN VOTE NO HOLE- WILL
WILL BE TAKING THIS UP TOMORROW
IN THE MEANTIME I'LL GO BACK
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE LIST
THAT I HAVE. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT ONE OF THE- THE THINGS
THAT WAS THAT WAS ELIMINATED IN
THE PROCESS. IS A NEGATIVE
DECLARATION POSSIBILITY FOR
SOME OF THAT- LICENSEES IN
SEQUEL- THAT DON'T REQUIRE A
FULL BLOWN PSYCHOANALYSIS. AND
WHEN YOU START TINKERING WITH
THAT KIND OF STUFF THEN YOU
HAVE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ON SOME OF THE
SMALLER AND SOME OF THE- THE-
THE KINDS OF C. CORE PROCESS
SEES WHERE THAT YOU WANT TO BE
FAIR AND SO I WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE LIST THAT WAS JUST.
A PROPOSED BY MY GOOD FRIEND I
WANT TO LOOK AT THE LIST THAT
I'VE GOT. AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED. THAT I WAS WORKING VERY
HARD ON OVER THE PAST FIVE
MONTHS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD
EVERYBODY. AT THE TABLE AND
THAT WE WERE NOT. PREJUDICING
BIG FARMERS AS OPPOSED TO SMALL
FARMERS AND- EIGHT PLACES WHERE
THERE HAD BEEN NO. ANNUAL
LICENSE ISSUED BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A PROCESS IN THEIR
COUNTY TO DO IT- WE WANT TO BE
FAIR IN THIS AND FRANKLY WANT
TO MAKE URE AGAIN THAT THOSE
THAT HAVE GOTTEN A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
WANT TO BE LEGAL THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO WANT TO PLAY THE GAME
AND REALLY WANT TO BE WITH US.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
THAT THE DRIVE HIM OUT OF THE
MARKET BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN A
HASTY ACTION HERE IN THIS- UP
PROCESS SO WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT EVERYBODY I'M GONNA LAY
OFF TODAY WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
LIST AND HOPE I CAN GET THERE
BY TOMORROW. SENATOR COPYRIGHT
PRESHEAF YOUR COMMENTS BECAUSE
IT IS CERTAINLY THE CASE THAT.
ANYONE WHO HAS GONE TO THE
TROUBLE WHETHER IT'S AT THE
FULL ON LICENSE OR
PROFESSIONAL. HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO OPERATE
LEGALLY AND WE KNOW. THAT
STILL. BE OF. UNFORTUNATELY THE
ILLICIT MARKET IS LARGER STILL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEN THE LEGAL MARKET. EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY MOVED
TO LEGALIZE CANNABIS. AND SO WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER. TO SUPPORT THAT LEGAL
MARKET THAT WAS ITS INTENTION
OF ITS CREATION. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT AS THEY
SAY. THE DEVIL IS IN THE
DETAILS. AND THAT THIS ONE-
FROM. A NUMBER OF YOU IT'S
CLEAR THIS ONE NEEDS MORE WORK.
I THINK SENATOR DOLE YOU PUT
YOUR MIKE UP GO AHEAD SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO ALSO.
SHARE THE FRUSTRATION I THINK
WE ALL FEEL AND I THINK THAT
THERE ISN'T REALLY A PERFECT
ANSWER TO THIS PROBLEM WE HAVE.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET THERE I
WE WORKED ON THIS IN THE SIMPLY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
YOU AFTER YOU'RE IN IN IN I
WILL SAY THAT THE NEW ATTORNEY
GENERAL- WAS ON THE WORKING A
PROBLEM TO WAS ON THE WORKING
GROUPS WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT. WE
CONTINUE TO JUST WITHIN ITS
SEQUEL ISN'T AN ISSUE BUT THE
BUT THEY ALSO WE NEED TO KEEP
IN MIND THAT THERE ARE STILL A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ILLEGALLY
GROWING OUT THERE ANDTHEY'RE
DOING A LOT TO THE ENVIRONMENT
IS NOT HEALTHY SPECIALLY DURING
THIS DROUGHT. AND THE SENATOR
FROM THE NORTH COAST AND MYSELF
WHO REPRESENT THOSE WATERSHEDS
THAT ARE REALLY IMPAIRED RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF DROUGHT IN THERE
ALSO STEALING WATER AND IN OFF.
WILDLIFE HABITAT ME THESE ARE
THESE ARE PLACES WHERE WE HAVE
CO SALMON AND WE HAVE
ENDANGERED SPECIES THAT NEED
WHAT LITTLE WATER PRECIOUS
WATERS THERE TO BE ABLE TO. TO
SPAWN AND IN THE LIKES THIS SO
I'M GONNA I WAS I I'VE HAD A
YES I HAD A NO AND I HAD TO LAY
OFF SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF TO AND
END IT DID TODAY THIS IS NO
THIS IS NOBODY'S FAULT WE-
THERE IS NO. PERFECT ANSWER FOR
THIS BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO THE ILLEGAL THE
LITTLE GROSS WE GO AFTER AND
STOP THE DATA DAMAGE WERE
HAVING TO THE ENVIRONMENT. AT
THE SAME TIME WE NEED TO GET
THE POPE PEOPLE TRYING TO BE
LEGAL IN A PROCESS WHERE THEY
CAN GET LEGAL AND MAKE IT MORE
ATTRACTIVE TO THEM SO THAT THEY
DON'T GO ILLEGAL BECAUSE IT'S
SO MUCH. THERE'S SUCH A TSUNAMI
OF ILLEGALS OUT THERE THAT WE
CAN'T EVEN PATROL MALL IS WE
NEED SOME HELP FROM THE AG'S
OFFICE TO GO AFTER THE ILLICIT
ONES THE ONES THAT ARE DOING IT
RIGHT I NEED TO HELP THE ONES
THAT ARE TRYING TO DO IT RIGHT
I KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE-
TRYING TO. STRIKE THE BALANCE
AND THAT'S WHAT I HEARD THEY
GET CENTER FROM NORTH COAST
SAYING AS WELL BUT IT IS
FRUSTRATING SO I WANNA BE ON
THAT TEAM I WANT TO HELP
BECAUSE IT DID IT INTO THE DAY
IS IN VIRANT LOSES AND IT'S
ALSO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING
TO DO GOOD BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR PRODUCT IS NOW
NATION MANY STATES OF CHANGE
OUR LAWS AS WELL SO WHEN YOU
LEAVE HERE- IT AND I WANT TO
JUST SAY I'M SUPPORTIVE. OF
HELPING THAT PROCESS ALONG.
THANK YOU- EITHER. AS FINANCING.
DEPARTMENT THAT. OFFICE AGAIN.
pCOMMENTS YOU WANT TO MAKE. SURE
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
KIMBERLY HARRISON AGAIN FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COMMENTS- REITERATE I THINK WE
ALL HAVE THE SAME GOAL WE ALL
WANT A HEALTHY LICENSED.
CANNABIS MARKET ACROSS THE
STATE WE ALL REALIZE THAT EACH
JURISDICTION IS DIFFERENT THEY
HAVE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
HUMBLE LOS ANGELES ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM ONE ANOTHER. SO
WE DO WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TO FIND A SOLUTION- SO THAT'S
OUR GOAL WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE GET INTO A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE AND THAT
THEY WORK TOWARD AN ANNUAL
LICENSE AT THEIR BENCHMARKS
ALONG THE WAY THERE ARE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT A CALL TO GROUPS
TO CONSIDER WE WANT TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AND- THAT WOULD
BE ENHANCED BY ESTABLISHING
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
TOMORROW AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S SEE ANY LAST
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL MOVE. TO A. B.
ONE FORTY THREE AND THAT IS THE
TRAILER BILL ON. THE COURTS. A
GO AHEAD DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
YES ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON AB ONE
FORTY THREE OF EIGHTY ONE FORTY
THREE EXPANDS ONLINE THE
ABILITY TO PAY PILOT PROGRAM
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT- STATEWIDE FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS TO APPLY ONLINE TO
HAVE THEIR FINES AND FEES FOR
TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS REDUCED BY AT LEAST
FIFTY PERCENT. IT ALLOWS ALL
COURT USERS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INCOME TO ADJUDICATE TRAFFIC
AND NON TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS
ONLINE EIGHTY ONE FORTY THREE
ALSO COMBINES THE IMMEDIATE AND
CRITICAL NEEDS ACCOUNTS AND THE
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND WHICH ARE THE
PRIMARY FUNDING SOURCES FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH FACILITIES
PROGRAM THIS WILL ALLOW THE
STATE PARK FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FINE TO REMAIN
SOLVENT IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND- PROMOTE EFFICIENCY FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH- A. B- HUH.
NUMBER EIGHTY ONE FORTY THREE
PROVIDES THE FUNDING ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY TO BACKFILL
COUNTIES FOR LOST REVENUES FROM
THE ELIMINATION OF SOME FINES
AND THE TYPES PURSUANT TO AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE. AND IT
AUTHORIZES THE G. JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO UTILIZE THE DESIGN
BUILD METHODOLOGY FOR FUTURE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS SIMILAR
TO OTHER STATE DEPARTMENTS
SPECIFICALLY THIS LANGUAGE WILL
MAKE EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM A
PERMANENT OPTION FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. AND THOSE ARE
SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE BILL
WE ARE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS. LET ME SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY BY MY COLLEAGUES. NOT
RIGHT NOW THIS ONE IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
WHICH IS. AB ONE FORTY FIVE.
AND IT IS- ON PUBLIC SAFETY
MAKES VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES
FOR OUR PUBLIC SAFETY RELATED
PROVISIONS OF THE BUDGET ACT GO
AHEAD PART IN FINANCE. ACTUALLY
IT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON EVEN ONE FORTY FIVE
THIS BILL PROVIDES AUTOMATIC
ARREST RECORD REALLY FOR
CERTAIN NONVIOLENT CRIMES
DATING BACK TO NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE. AND EXPANDS THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS FROM SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY ONE COMMISSIONERS IT
CREATES A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
PLACEMENT OF LOCAL JUSTICE
INVOLVED JUVENILE WARDS AT PINE
GROVE YOUTH CAN CONSERVATION
CAMP TO PROVIDE THEM WITH JOB
TRAINING AND RE ENTRY
OPPORTUNITIES. IT IS ALMOST AS
A COUNTY RESENTENCING A PILOT
PROGRAM TO FIND DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICES TO PETITION FOR
REQUESTS FOR RESENTENCING. IT
PROVIDES AUTHORITY FOR BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
REPRESENTATIVES TO MAKE
UNANNOUNCED JAIL INSPECTIONS
AND EXPANDS THE ALLOWABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR REIMBURSEMENT
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMINATIONS- THOSE ARE SOME
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE BILL AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS. BUT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
ONE. SEEING NONE. WE WILL GO TO
THE NEXT AVAILABLE. WHICH IS
EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE AND ITS
TRANSPORTATION. THANK YOU-
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AB ONE FORTY NINE-
DISPEL EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION ACT OR
NEPA DELEGATION FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS FROM TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT
PROVIDES OR EXTEND STATUTORY
RELIEF TO TRANSIT AGENCIES
IMPACTED BY THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IT ALSO INCLUDES
IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE FOR CLEAN
FOR THE CLEAN CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE- CLEAN CALIFORNIA
WILL ENHANCE HELP CALTRANS
LITTLE LITTER REMOVAL
ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS THAT CAUSE
LETTER- EIGHT EIGHTY ONE FORTY
NINE EXTENDS FROM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY. THREE THE 10%
CAP THAT CALTRANS CAN CHARGE
SELF HELP COUNTIES FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION PORTION OF ITS
INDIRECT COST RECOVERY CHARGES
TO SELF HELP COUNTRIES. EIGHTY
ONE FORTY NINE PROVIDES CITIES
AND COUNTIES TEMPORARY RELIEF
FROM MAINTENANCE OF EFFORT
REQUIREMENTS IN THE SP ONE
LOCAL STREETS AND ROADS PROGRAM.
AND THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
TEN MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR GM
NEEDS TO DEVELOP A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR MOBILE DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN. THE BUDGET ACT- THE
PILOT PROGRAM IS EXPECTED TO
RUN FROM JULY OF THIS YEAR
THROUGH MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. OF EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE
ESTABLISHES PRIVACY SAFEGUARDS
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THOSE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM
THE BILL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
TRANSPORTATION- CLEARLY THE
CONTINUED RELIEF TO OUR TRANSIT
AGENCIES IS VERY IMPORTANT THEY
WERE- HIT SEVERELY- TO THE DROP
IN RIDERSHIP DURING THE
PANDEMIC SO FEAR BOXES WENT WAY
WAY I MEAN I THINK THEY LOST
MORE THAN 90% UNFAIR BOX. SO
THIS PART IS VERY IMPORTANT- I
DON'T SEE ANY ACT YES GO AHEAD
SENATOR KABIR THINK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I WANT A
SECOND THAT I RECEIVED A NUMBER
OF CAN. A LOT OF CONCERN WAS
RAISED BY THE FAREBOX RECOVERY-
OBLIGATION I DON'T THINK THAT
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES AND
GOTTEN BACK ON THEIR FEET AGAIN
AND PEOPLE DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE I'M WRITING IN THE
NUMBERS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED IN ORDER FOR THEM TO GET
THE FAREBOX RECOVERY SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS ADDITION
TO THE- TO THE BUDGET- AND ALSO
THERE IS A PROGRAM THAT WILL-
PROVIDE. A SMALL INCENTIVE TO-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WILL
PARTICIPATE IN CLEANING THE
HIGHWAY AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS
A REALLY GOOD ADDITION TO THE
BUDGET AS WELL OUR HIGHWAYS ARE
LOOKING PARTICULARLY POOR. I'M
PARTICULARLY IN URBAN AREAS
WHERE. PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN TO
LIVING AND THEN WENT UNDER
PASSES AND THE TRASH BLOWS ON
TO THE ROADWAY AND ON TO THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD- I JUST WANT
TO- CAUTION. THIS MAY BE NEED
TO BE A PILOT FOR A PROJECT FOR
AWHILE BECAUSE- OF SOME OF THE
TRASH WILL BE. UP PRETTY BAD.
BECAUSE OF THE HOMELESS
SITUATION AND WE ACTUALLY MAY
NEED- CREWS THAT HAVE THAT HAVE
A BETTER- THE CAPACITY TO PICK
UP. ON SANITARY MATERIALS AND
DISPOSE OF THEM IN A WAY THAT-
THAT YOU WOULDN'T WANT. YOU
KNOW LIKE A BASEBALL TEAM GOING
OUT AND PICKING UP SOME OF THIS
TRASH WOULDN'T WANT YOUNG
PEOPLE DOING IT KIDS RIGHT IN
OTHER WORDS SO. I JUST I
MENTIONED THAT I THINK IT'S A
GREAT PROGRAM- IT IT IS IN
ADDITION TO THE BUDGET AND I
THINK IT. BUT WE MAY NEED TO.
USE A MORE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AS WELL. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT
ITEM THE NEXT RULER BILL WHICH
IS EIGHTY ONE FIFTY AND IT'S
THE SALES AND USE TAX LAW- GO
AHEAD- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT
CAREFULLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE EIGHT ONE FIFTY
CONTAINS MOST OF THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT ARE PART OF THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT INCLUDING SOME OF THE
FOLLOWING- THE MAIN STREET TO
HIRING CREDIT EXPANDS THE
CREDIT BY ALLOCATING ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN MILLION TO
PROVIDE RELIEF TO BUSINESSES
WITH UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES THAT SHOWED A YEAR
OVER YEAR DROP OF AT LEAST 20%
GROSS RECEIPTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY- THE OMELESS HIRING
CREDIT WHICH ALLOCATES THIRTY
MILLION PER YEAR FOR A TAX
CREDIT FOR HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
WITH- HEY AT LEAST A 120% OF
MINIMUM WAGE. HELLO COMPUTER
EXPANSION THIS INCREASES THE
ANNUAL CAL COMPETES ALLOCATION
BY A HUNDRED TEN- TWO TWO
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION I DON'T
WANT TEN BASES IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND ELECTED PASTOR
ENERGY TAX WHICH ALLOWS CERTAIN
BUSINESSES BUSINESS OWNERS TO
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF FEDERAL
TAX LEGISLATION ENACTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT CAPS THE
AMOUNT OF STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES. CAN BE DEDUCTED FROM
FEDERAL INCOME AX RETURNS AT
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS- THOSE ARE
SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM THIS BILL
AND- AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. LET ME SEE IF
ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
QUESTIONS ON THIS ONE. I DON'T
SEE ANY BUT I WILL SAY AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
I'M VERY VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THAT. THE SALES TAX EXEMPTION
FOR MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS. AND
DIAPERS ARE NOW BEING MADE
PERMANENT WITH IN THIS BUDGET
IN THIS TRAILER BILL. SOMETHING
THAT- THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS
ADVOCATED FOR A GOOD LONG TIME.
AND OBVIOUSLY ESSENTIAL NEEDS A
CENTRAL PRODUCTS. AND GIVEN
THAT WE DO NOT. PUT SALES TAX
ON. FOOD AND OTHER ESSENTIAL
ITEMS. THE SIMILARLY SHOULD NOT
ON THESE SO REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
IT. RIGHT WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT.
ARM YES CENTER GROVE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN I
KNOW THERE'S LIKE THREE PIECES
OF PLEXIGLASS BETWEEN US BUT I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS AND I'D LIKE TO THINK
AND THE BUDGET HERE TO THE END
THE DIRECTOR AS WELL YOU KNOW
SOME OF THESE TAX CREDITS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
WE'LL PROVIDE LONG TERM SUPPORT
TO BUSINESSES- AND ALSO. WITH
THE REVIEW RECENT ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE AND NEED TO DO
ESPECIALLY WITH THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IS TRY TO GET
INCENTIVIZE BUSINESS TO HIRE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HOMELESS OR
THAT AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT CAN
START AN ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS
OR FIND SKILLED INDIVIDUALS OUT
IN THE HOMELESS COMMUNITY THAT
CHEST HAVE HAD A BAD RUN A LUCK
SO- I APPRECIATE ALL THOSE-
INCENTIVE INCENTIVES THAT ARE
THERE. AND THEN- I- I JUST
APPRECIATE IT DOES IT THE
INFORMATION IT'S IN THIS
TRAILER BILL AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING AND THANK YOU
BOTH I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
WORKING HARD TO GET THIS DONE.
SENATOR GROVE I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND ESPECIALLY. YOUR
REFERENCE TO THAT IN FACT. SOME
OF OUR OWN HOUSE TO PEOPLE ARE
PEOPLE THAT JUST HAD A BAD RUN
OF LUCK. THEY ARE NOT- SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL OR HAVE SEVERE
DISAFFECTION STAY. IT'S THE AS
THEY SAY THE SAYING THERE BUT
FOR FORTUNE. AND SO- IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO. IF THEY ARE
WILLING AND ABLE TO WORK. TO
GIVE THEM EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
AND THIS. CREDIT DOES THAT SO
APPRECIATE THAT- WILL NOW GO
TO. SENATOR EDMUND GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S
BEEN SAID SO FAR UP AND I JUST
WANT TO CALLOUT ONE MORE TO
HIS THE- FOOD AND FOOD DONATION
TAX CREDIT. FOR OUR AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY IT IS YOU KNOW WE'VE
SAID IT MANY TIMES THAT WE ARE
THE- RICHEST STATE IN
AGRICULTURE AND WE ALSO HAVE A
WHOLE LOT OF HUNGER IT MAKES NO
SENSE TO NOT TO BE ABLE TO PAIR
THOSE. TWO THINGS TOGETHER SO
THAT WE'RE ABLE TO KEEP
CONTINUING THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT SCENARIO I WORKED ON
A LOT. AND I'M GLAD TO SEE THAT
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE PEOPLE
GET FED AND FARMERS ARE ABLE TO
HAVE A PLACE TO PUT THEIR-
ACCESS THANKS. THANK YOU. GREAT
LET'S GO TO A. B. ONE FIFTY
ONE. THAT IS THE- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- TRAILER BILL. GO
AHEAD. DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR KELLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THIS WILL CREATE.
THE CAL COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES GRANTS TO
BUSINESSES THAT MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA- THE BUDGET INCLUDES
THIRTY FIVE. MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FUND TO PROVIDE
MICROGRAMS. UP TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO ELIGIBLE
START UPS TO CEDE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP AND SMALL
BUSINESSES- SMALL BUSINESS
CREATION IN UNDERSERVED SMALL
BUSINESS GROUPS THAT ARE FACING
CAPITAL AND- OPPORTUNITY GAPS.
IT IS NOT MUCH IS THAT
CALIFORNIA VENUES AND GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO INDEPENDENT VENUES
LIVE EVENTS BUSINESSES. LIVE
EVENT. BUSINESSES AND MINOR
LEAGUE SPORTS. ESTABLISHES THE
CALIPER MICRO BUSINESS KOBE
NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM
WITHIN- THE CALLOW SBA- THE
SMALL BUSINESS. ADMINISTRATION
TO ASSIST QUALIFIED MICRO
BUSINESSES AND HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE CLUB
IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
FINALLY INSTEAD IT ESTABLISHES
THE I HAVE TO PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE IT FOCUS ON
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
IN THE STATES TECH AND SCIENCE
BASED START UP ECOSYSTEM- THOSE
ARE SOME NOTABLE HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THE BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ON THIS BILL. WELL I WILL MAKE
ONE THAT GO AHEAD SENATOR
CAFIERO. YES MANAGER I JUST
WANT TO CALL OUT IN IN THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
SO HARD ON THE CALIFORNIA MICRO
BUSINESS- GRANT RELIEF PROGRAM
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE STAFF
THIS WAS PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE ONCE WE DID THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS. BUT IT'S HARD
TO REACH DEEP ENOUGH INTO THE
COMMUNITY GET THE MICRO MICRO
BUSINESSES- AND WE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH A STRATEGY THAT WOULD
INCLUDE THEM IN IN A GRANT
PROGRAM AD IT'S IN THE BUDGET.
I'M REALLY HAPPY THERE ARE A
LOT OF VERY VERY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT THIS IS HOW
SMALL BUSINESSES START THEY
START AS A ONE PERSON SHOW THEY
MAY BE WORKING OUT OF THEIR
THEIR OWN HOUSE- BUT- THERE IS
BUT- MONEY IN THE BUDGET AND
I'M I WANNA I WANNA SAY THANK
YOU TO EVERYBODY THAT MADE IT
HAPPEN. WHEN SENATOR CAFIERO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STRONG
ADVOCACY ON IT BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT'S WHAT HELPED PULL IT ALL
TOGETHER. AND I WILL MAKE A
SIMILAR COMMENT ABOUT BOTH THE-
NONPROFIT- CULTURAL INSTITUTION
GRANTS AND THE VENUE'S PROGRAM.
AND I'M SOMEONE WHO. WHEN
THERE'S NOT A PANDEMIC AND
WHEN- I'M ABLE TO- NOT YOU KNOW
BE AT HOME. WHAT MY WHAT MY
HUSBAND AND I LOVE MOST TO DO
IS TO GO HEAR LIVE MUSIC AND OR
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY THEATERS
YOU KNOW ENJOY THOSE KINDS OF-
ARTS AND CULTURAL- I DID THE
RICHNESS THAT THERE IS IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND OF COURSE WE
KNOW UNDER THE PANDEMIC LIKE SO
MANY OTHER BUSINESSES THEY HAD
TO CLOSE COMPLETELY. AND MANY
OF THEM ARE YOU KNOW BEAT THE
AS WE KNOW WITH THE ARTS
INSTITUTIONS THERE THEY ARE
HARDLY MAKING IT AS IT IS AND
SO THIS IS GOING TO GO A LONGWAYS TOWARDS MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN BRING BACK LIVE MUSIC
LIVE THEATER AND SO MANY OTHER
OF THOSE- CULTURAL ENJOYMENTS
ENTERTAINMENT THAT WE ENJOY SO
I REALLY AM A HUGE SUPPORTER OF
THAT PART. OF THIS TRAILER BILL.
CORRECT WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT
ITEM. AND THAT IS. AB ONE FIFTY
SEVEN AND THAT IS ON THE CRIME
PREVENTION ENFORCEMENT AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES DEFINITELY WITHIN
PERMANENT FINANCE ON AB ONE
FIFTY SEVEN- THIS BILL REMOVES
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AS AN
ENTITY ADMINISTERING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CIRCUIT
PROSECUTOR GRANT PROGRAM- AND
AS AN ENTITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS- AND IT IS
DELICIOUS THE GRANT PROGRAM
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AGENCY- AND AUTHORIZES. THAT
AGENCY CAL EPA TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO QUALIFIED GRANTEES
TO ADMINISTER THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT EDUCATION
TRAININGS. I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS BILL.
HIGHLY SEE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT. MY COLLEAGUES
OUT FOR COMMENT. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NINE WE WILL GO TO THE
PUBLIC- COMMENT PORTION OF OUR
HEARING AND LET ME SEE FRST IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OUR MAIN-
COMMITTEE ROOM HERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE US PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. SIR ANYONE HERE. THE
CASE SEEING YOU YOU ARE PRESENT
YOU DO WANT TO MAKE GIFT BUT
THEN GO TO THE MIKE PLEASE
INDICATE YOUR NAME. AND
ORGANIZATION AND WHAT YOU'RE
COMMENTING ON. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR SKINNER AND
MEMBERS MY NAME ISROSCO P. ON
YOUNG ONCE A STAFFER SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA CONTRA
COSTA TRANSIT DIRECTOR JOVANKA
BECKLES INSTRUCTS THE PORT OF
EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE- THIS
BILL IS NOT JUST A RELIEF FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES IT'S A
LIFESAVER FOR OUR RESIDENTS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND OUR BUS
OPERATORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BUT LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ELSE- COURT YES THERE IS GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
STORES WITH STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA FIRST ONE EXTEND
A HUGE THANK YOU TO YOURSELF
MADAM CHAIR ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE- ESPECIALLY
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO TOOK A
EXTENSIVE TIME DEVOTED. TO
DEVELOPING THE LANGUAGE
CONTAINING THE BODIES GRANT
PROGRAM WE'RE SO GRATEFUL FOR
THE WORK DONE AND LISTENING TO
THE HUNDREDS OF VENUES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND VENUES ALL
THROUGHOUT YOUR YOUR DISTRICTS-
THEY BADLY NEED RELIEF AND THIS
REALLY. THAT THE GOLDEN STATE
STEPPING UP TO HELP PROVIDE
SOME OF THAT RELIEF WE WERE
THRILLED TO SEE THAT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH TELL US
ABOUT A ROLE THE PROGRAM OUT
EFFICIENTLY AND AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK TO HELP
SAVE OUR CALIFORNIA STATUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HI I DON'T
SEE ANY OTHERS IN THIS- IN OUR
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO'S MAKING A
PUBLIC COMMENT SO LET ME LOOK
AT THE OUR OVERFLOW ROOM AND
SEEING NONE THERE WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE THE
PHONE LINES- LET ME READ THAT.
NUMBER AGAIN FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WANT TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS VIA OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
THREE ONE SEVEN EIGHT THREE
THREE SIX. SO MODERATOR YOU
COULD QUEUE UP ANY OF THOSE WHO
ARE- IN LINE TO COMMENT.
ABSOLUTELY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AS WE GO TO LINE TWO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS AND
ALSO BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T MAKE
IT ON THE CALL ON BEHALF OF THE
U. S. AND W. IN SUPPORT OF A B.
ONE FORTY ONE AND THAT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE A CANNABIS.
TRAINABLE BELL LANGUAGE- WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
PRIORITIZE REGULATION OF THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CRITICAL ISSUES
FACED BY STAKEHOLDERS SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR. INCLUDING THE ASSURANCE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
AND X. EXPANSION OF EQUITY
PROGRAMS WELL THERE'S ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN LANGUAGE THE
SLIGHTEST LEGISLATION OVERALL
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
PROGRESS IN THE REGULATION OF
THIS INDUSTRY AND WE SUPPORTED
THE PASSAGE IN AN ACCIDENT.
THANK YOU. MODERATOR NEXT THANK
YOU TO CLIENTS. THANKS TO THE
TWENTY TWO OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER NOT YOUR MOMMA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE THREE
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
LEADERSHIP IN PUSHING THE RATE
INCREASES FOR PROGRAMS FOR
PEOPLE WITH AN OPTION TO
INSTABILITY SH THE RESTORATION
OF SOCIAL- RECKON CAN'T
SERVICES DELIMITATION OF
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE. IN
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX THE
GENERAL NINETEEN RATE THIRTY
CALLED FOR BY THE LEGISLATURE
ANOTHER SYSTEM WAS UNDERFUNDED
BY ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION EACH
AND WHILE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE AND
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S LEADERSHIP WHEN
ALLOCATION OF BEAT UP BUT WE
NEED TO FIND WE DO WANT TO WARN
THAT THE FIRST TWO TWENTY
TWENTY TO IMPLEMENT THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE WELL NOT
QUITE URGENT NEED THE SYSTEM
FACES. PRETTY PANDEMIC ARE YOU
HARD TO TALK ABOUT DIFFICULTIES
FINDING HERE TRAINING QUALITY
STAFF. AND PROGRAMS ARE NOW
RESTARTING THE PROBLEM HAVE
COMPOUNDED AND WE URGE YOU TO
CHANGE THE DATE TO JULY ONE
IMPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- NEXT TO THE TO LINE
TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTER GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION AND THE FORTY FIVE
LOCAL WORKFORCE BOARDS. ACROSS
THE STATE WOULD LIKE TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE FIFTY PARTICULARLY THE
HOMELESS HIRING TAX CREDIT.
THIS CREDIT WILL HELP TO
CONNECT ON THE HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH BUSINESSES
LOOKING TO BOUNCE BACK FROM THE
NUMEROUS ISSUES THEY FACE AND
ULTIMATELY. LIST BOTH OF THEM
UP AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
BUILD BACK WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE BUDGET STAFF
AND SENATOR ROSALYN HER STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE. AND WE HEARD YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD ONE
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MARTY A MOTO- A FAMILY MEMBER
OF AN OLDER SISTER WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ALSO
UNPAID CARE GIVER OF AN
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBER THE
TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD WITH DOWN
SYNDROME AND ON THE SPECTRUM
WHO LIVES WITH ME- ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR REACHING
SUBCOMMITTEES. AND I JUST-
WANTED TO FIRST OF ALL I THINK
THE- THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR REMARKABLE
TRANSFORMING BUDGET- STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
SIX- AND ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER ON
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- ALSO
JUST WANT TO SHOUT OUT FOR
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY- CHILDREN
THREE TO FOUR WITH THE
TRADITIONAL ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
LANHAM ACT- STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE EXTRA FOR THE FUNDING FOR
THE RATE STUDY LINKED TO PERSON
CENTRED OUTCOMES. WHICH WE
THINK WILL HELP- REDUCE UNMET
NEED. AND DISPARITIES BUT WE
AREN'T SURE- INCLUSION OF
SERVICES NOT INCLUDED IN THE
RATE SETTING INCLUDING HOUSING
SERVICES WHICH ARE VERY
CRITICAL LASTLY. WE WANT A-
URGE STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. H. C.
B. S. SPENDING PLAN THAT WAS
RELEASED ON JUNE THIRD. LOOK AT
THE WHOLE PERSON CROSSING ALL
SYSTEM LINES. OF DISABILITY
AGING AND MENTAL HEALTH.
WILLING TO- PERSON CENTERED
OUTCOMES AND WE THINK THAT WILL
HELP REDUCE. ACHIEVE EQUITY
THAT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA LAST WEEK JUST WANT
TO THANK. YOU THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR SENATOR
EDMUND. AND B. L. A. IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER A REMARKABLE BUDGET
AND ACTUALLY WAS BEING
RESPONSIVE TO ALL OF US- WE'RE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE TO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED TO JORDAN
AND THE WHAT'S THE ARCANE
UNITED CIRCLE CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIONS AND I
ECHOED SIMILAR SENTIMENTS THAT
ALREADY BEEN MADE ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TRAVEL
THE LANGUAGE AND FUDGES
ACTIONS- IT REALLY IS COMBINED
WITH THE HOME COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES. SPENDING PLAN IT CAN
BE TRANSFORMATIVE FOR COMMUNITY
AND SO I JUST WANT TO ADD A
COUPLE QUICK COMMENTS ON TOP OF
IT- ONE THING IS TO UNDERSCORE
MADAM CHAIR WHAT YOU SAID
EARLIER WHICH IS THAT WE DO
HOPE LIKE YOU MENTIONED. THAT
REVENUES ARE SUCH THAT WE CAN'T
IMPLEMENT THAT SOONER THAN PART
WITH THE RATE STUDY PORTION OF
THE BUDGET SOONER THAN YOUR
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX- AND WE
WILL BE GLAD TO WORK WITH YOU
ON THAT. SECOND JUST AGAIN WANT
TO REITERATE TO THE AMAZING
WORK DONE BY LA HELLO THE STAFF
THE COMMITTEE. AND THEN FINALLY
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT THIS
IS THE RIGHT STUDY IN
PARTICULAR IT'S BEEN YEARS IN
THE MAKING AND SO THERE ARE A
LOT OF RECOGNITION OVER THE
YEARS EVEN DATING BACK TO A
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUE SENATOR BELL
A PREVIOUS JOB YOU NEED SURE
SENATOR PAN CURRENT. INSURANCE
ENTERTAINMENT AND MANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF THOSE COMMITTEES AND
JUST KEEP PREACHING
APPRECIATION FOR THE
CULMINATION OF THE YEARS OF
EFFORT. INTO THIS BUDGET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MEXICO CAROLINA ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CHICKEN-
NUMBERS NINE LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
COMMENTING ON EIGHTY ONE FIFTY
ONE. WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF NON PROFITS IN THE
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM THE ADDITIONAL CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS GRANT ROUNDS AND
THE NEW FUNDING FOR PERFORMING
ARTS NONPROFIT FANS AND FOR
VENUES. BUT IN OUR ROLE AS THE
VOICE FOR NONPROFITS HELLO
GOING INTO THE CONTRACTED
PARTNER FOR THE RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM. WE ARE CONTINUING TO
HEAR FROM APPLICANTS ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS INCLUDING
THOUSANDS OF NONPROFITS
COMPLETED THE WRONG APPLICATION
BECAUSE THE NONPROFIT
APPLICATION BUT NOT IMMEDIATELY
THAT THE BALL ON THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR EIGHT. APPLICANTS
WHO COMPLETE THE WRONG
APPLICATION DID NOT RECEIVE
ADEQUATE NOTICE ABOUT THEIR
ERROR AND DESPITE COMPLETING
ALL OTHER REQUIRED PAPERWORK
WERE DENIED A GRANT. AND THIRD
NONPROFIT APPLICANTS RECEIVED
POOR CUSTOMER SERVICE AND MIXED
MESSAGES FROM THE
INTERMEDIARIES CALL CENTER
THESE ISSUES ARE LIKELY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE LOW
PERCENTAGE OF THE GRANT'S GOING
TO NONPROFITS. THREE POINT 2%
ACROSS THE FIVE GENERAL ROUNDS
AND ONLY ONE POINT 8% FOR
AROUND FIVE THE LAST ROUND BUT
FINALIZED DATA. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION ON WAYS TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO NON PROFITS TO
BETTER SUPPORT THEM AS THEY
RESPOND TO COMMUNITY NEEDS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF YASSER
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS AND WE DO HAVE A
COMMENT I'M CONCERNED ATTENTION
CONCERN ON EIGHTY ONE FORTY
THREE RELATED TO THE COURT-
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE
REGARDING ONLINE- EDUCATION OF
TRAFFIC MATTERS. WE DO HAVE A
CONCERN TO THE EXTENT THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW FOR REMOTE-
HEARINGS- FOR INFRACTIONS UNDER
EXTENDED THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
IT TO BE THAT WE ARE CONCERNED
BECAUSE THERE NEEDS TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AS TO WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE NEEDS AN
INTERPRETER- THERE'VE BEEN
PILOT PROJECT. TO ALLOW FOR
REMOTE APPEARANCES TO
INTERPRETERS HAVE BEEN REQUIRED
TO BE PERSONALLY PRESENT WITH-
THE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TRAFFIC
MATTERS-AND LA COUNTY HAS HAD.
A PRACTICE DURING THE PANDEMIC
TO ALLOW FOR BUT NOT DURING
TRIALS. AND SO WE JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THIS SHOULD NOT
OCCUR DURING TRIALS WE WANT TO
HAVE A VERY SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
IN TURN TRIGGERS ARE AVAILABLE-
AND THE RIGHT PROCESSES ARE IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THE INDIVIDUALS
IN THE NEED OF INTERPRETERS
HAVE THEM AND HAVE THEM IN THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE. ALSO THE
EXTENT OF THE BILL WOLD ALLOW
FOR THAT WE CAN GET THERE'S
MORE. WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE BEFORE IT SHOULD GO FOR.
THANK YOU. MEXICO THAILAND TO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRWOMAN-
BIANCA BROWN PLACED ON BEHALF
OF SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY. OF
HONOR DURING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT I BE ONE FIFTY ONE
BE AMENDED COULD BUILD UPON THE
ENORMOUS EXPECT THEM AND TRADED
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL AND-
EXPANSION PROGRAM- WE REFLECT
THAT HE PROGRAM IS EXTENDED
BEYOND ITS FIVE YEAR PILOT. AND
SECOND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FIND. FUNCTIONS AS A
SEPARATE PROGRAM HE PAID BY
ADDING SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR INTENSIVE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
TRAINING. AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMMATIC ELEMENTS ARE
INCLUDED I EIGHTY TEN SEVENTY
TWO AND FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE.
I HAD MY BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
RELYING ON OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES NOW MORE
THAN EVER SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT
AT. THE ONE FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WITH THE
TWO LINES TWO FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF ABI ON HEALTHCARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THIRTY OR
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX AND IT'S
A PHASE IN OF THE DDS RIGHT
STUDY. I'M ON BEHALF OF CMG
KHALIFA. VERY REGRETFULLY IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO
EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE.
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
BOTH SENATORS CALERO AND
REQUIRE RELATIVE TO THE ISSUES-
THAT STILL NEED TO BE FIXED THE
ONE THAT I HAVE NOT HEARD MUCH
SAID ABOUT. THEM IS THE ONE
THAT CONCERNS US THE MOST AND
THAT IS THE MID SIZE AND LARGER
CULTIVATORS WHO WOULD BE FORCED
TO TRANSITION TO A- ANNUAL
LICENSE IN THE FIRST YEAR
RATHER THAN THE FOUR YEARS
AFFORDED TO EVERYBODY ELSE.
THAT ONE YEAR IS NOT ENOUGH
TIME TO GET THOSE LICENSES NOT
DEALT WITH WHICH MEANS THAT
THOSE- THOSE COMPANIES AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THEIR TAX
GENERATION WILL PROBABLY
DISAPPEAR AT THE END OF THAT
YEAR IF WE DON'T FIX THAT- WE
DO HOPE THAT THAT ISSUE WILL BE
ADDRESSED IN- IN A FOLLOW UP
BILL THAT- THAT BOASTS AND
RECOVER YOUR- INSTEAD OF
ACQUIRING REFERRED TO. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO THE TO LINE TO
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BEVERLY ON BEHALF TO UW AND
SUPPORT EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE IT
WAS A LIAR COMMENTS WITH HER
LABOR COLLEAGUES HERE WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK BY THE
MINISTRATION LEGISLATURE MAKING
THE TRAILER BILL PICTURE THE
FACT THAT THE GROWING INDUSTRY
AFTER ALL THE CONSOLIDATION
EFFORT. WHAT LANGUAGE TO HELP
PROVIDE A LEGAL PATHWAY FOR
OPERATORS TO MAINTAIN
COMPLIANCE THE PAYMENT IN YOUR
LIFE AND- HIRING A DEPUTY
DIRECTOR EQUITY INCLUSION AND
ALLOCATIONS. THE COURT THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS EQUITY ACT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI THIS IS CLAUDIA
V. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU-
THANK YOU- SHARE AND- BUT YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI SERVICE
THE ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA
DOUBLE WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER
NETWORK OF THE SIXTEEN WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS SERVING OVER
TWELVE THOUSAND- WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS IN OUR STATE I'M
CALLING WITH SEVERE CONCERNS
ABOUT EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE AND
URGING YOU TO AMEND IT AS
FOLLOWS- WE'RE ASKING YOU TO
SEPARATE THE NEW. THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR DREAM FIND
DIRECT GRANT PROGRAM TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THE EXISTING SMALL
BUSINESS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXPANSION PROGRAM HEY. AND ALSO
ASKING YOU TO ADD SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE COST OF
ITS INTENSIVE SCREENING
TRAINING AND COACHING AS WELL
AS THE MANAGEMENT AND DATA
COLLECTION NEEDED TO MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL. FEATURING GRANT
FUNCTIONS ARE REALLY OVER AND
ABOVE THE CURRENT SERVICES
PROVIDED BY YOUR TAPE GRANTEES
WHO OPERATE IN YOUR LOCAL
DISTRICTS. I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE LOTS OF THE
TWENTY ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN SHARES ACT FUNDING
FOR KATE GRANTEES AFTER
SEPTEMBER THIS YEAR THIS IS
GOING TO PUT MORE PRESSURE ON
THE PROGRAMS. YOU KNOW THAT
DEMAND REMAINS HIGH FROM SMALL
BUSINESSES AND YOU SAW THE OVER
FOUR HUNDRED LETTERS THAT WE
GENERATED WERE SENT IN SUPPORT
OF FINDING FOUR K. PLEASE DO
NOT CANNIBALIZE YOUR EXISTING
AND ALREADY PRESSED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO ADD NEW
PROGRAMS WITHOUT NEW FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THEM. AND IF THE GREEN
GRANT FUNDS ARE TO REACH THE
FOLKS WHO REALLY NEED THEM IT
SHOULD BE SEPARATED FROM THE
EXISTING PAY AND HAVE
ADDITIONAL SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR OPERATIONS. THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE TWO THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M ACTUALLY WARNER WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PM AND THEN TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT OVER INSURE
EFFECTIVE USE OF FUNDS FROM
FOURTEEN OF OUR STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. IT IS
CRITICAL FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WE WORK WITH IN THE
DAN I CAN VALLEY IN THE EAST
COACHELLA VALLEY WHICH ARE
IMPACTED BY MULTIPLE SOURCES OF
POLLUTION WHICH ARE OFTEN THE
RESULT OF UNCHECKED VIOLATIONS
OF ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANKS SO MUCH THANK YOU.
THANKS GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JULIE
BAKER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES CALLING TO
SHOW OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE AND
PARTICULARLY CALIFORNIA
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS GRANT
PROGRAM THE NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS AND CALIFORNIA
LIVE EVENTS PROGRAM FOR THE
COUNTRY AND OUR CULTURE MIGHT.
INDUSTRIES AND WORKFORCE SHOULD
OFTEN EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE CLEAN
CALIFORNIA LOCAL GRANT PROGRAM
AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH AN
EMPHASIS TO INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
ARGENTINA GRANT PROGRAMS TO
BEAUTIFYING CLEAN UP LOCAL
STREETS AND ROADS TRIBAL LANDS
PARKS COPLEY TRANSIT CENTERS
AND OTHER PUBLIC SPACES. ARE
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
KENYA'S MAY REVIVE PUBLIC
ARTWORK CAN ADD VALUE TO A
PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCIES PRIMARY
GOAL OF BUILDING RIDERSHIP FIND
CASEY TYPING CHOICE WRITERS NO
TRACKING NEW WRITERS EDITORS
VANDALISM AMONG OTHER BENEFITS.
OF THE DIFFERENT EXPRESS OUR
DEEP APPRECIATION FOR ALL YOUR
WORK ON THE BUDGET TO INCLUDE
HISTORIC INVESTMENT FOR ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVITY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU. MEXICO
TO LINE TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S FINE HELLO CLIENT
OF. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU TO A
SIX. HI HELLO. GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS EMPOWER DALLAS AND I
JUST WANTED TO. THANK YOU GUYS
FOR SUPPORTING- EIGHT X. B. ONE
THIRTY SIX I AM THE PARENT OF
THE STAKEHOLDER OF REGIONAL
CENTER FOR THIRTY NINE YEARS.
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR YOU
GUYS TAKE A LOOK AT IT AT THIS
TIME BECAUSE WE HAD LOST A LOT
OF THINGS BUT A LOT OF YEARS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS. AND
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. LIKE TO
GO TO LINE TWO OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS PER QUINTAL TO
HERE WITH THAT APEX GROUP ON
BEHALF OF CURE LEASE AND
PERFECT UNION WE'D LIKE TO
VOICE OUR OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON A. B. ONE FOUR ONE.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS DUE TO
THE RESTRICTIVE AND FRANKLY
UNDER UNATTAINABLE TIMELINE FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSES. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MADE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND COPY ERRO-
THANK YOU SO MUCH BYE BYE.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THE
CLIENT TWO OH ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL TO ALIGN TO
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. YES-
I'M COPING TO SUPPORT MAY BE
SIXTY NINE- FOR MY KIDS BECAUSE
I HAVE TWO KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. AND I CALLING TO- THE
BLAZE- LOCALLY AND- YOU CANNOT
COLLECT. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE TO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE ORIGINS COUNSEL
REPRESENTING LEGACY CULTIVATORS
IN TRINITY SIMILAR MENDOCINO
NEVADA AND MONTEREY COUNTIES WE
APPRECIATE THE EXTENSIVE
ENGAGEMENT BY THE LEGISLATURE
ON EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE SP ONE
FORTY ONE THE CHEMISTRY REBELS.
VERTICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
EXTENDING THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSING PROGRAM AND
PROTECTING THE EXISTING
COMMUNITY FROM LIFE AND
DESTRUCTION BUT WE WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS MEASURE NO
WAY ADDRESSES SYSTEMIC
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS. WITH THE
STATE LICENSING SYSTEM THAT ARE
CAUSING THESE BARRIERS TO ENTRY.
AND CREATING DELAYS IN MOVING
FROM A PROVISIONAL TUNING A
PROCESS. FURTHER THIS BILL
RAISES ADDITIONAL BARRIERS BY
SHUTTING THE DOOR FOR SMALL
ACQUIRING BUSINESSES THAT
APPLY. FOR PROVISIONAL LICENSES
WITHIN THE NEXT NINE MONTHS AND
THAT'S A PARTICULAR HARDSHIP
FOR REGIONS AROUND THE STATE
THAT ARE JUST STANDING UP THERE
ORDINANCES INCLUDING THE BIG
SUR REGION- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE WILL BE A CLEANUP
LANGUAGE THROUGH SUBSEQUENT
TRAILER TRAILER BILL WE WANT TO
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY. SENATOR
MCGUIRE EARLIER. IT RISKS TO
PROVISIONAL LICENSEES OR DENIED
RIGHT OF APPEAL AND THAT SHOOT.
AND THE SUSPENSION OR
REVOCATION OF THEIR LICENSES
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
BUT RATHER DUE TO INACTION. OR
ACTION BY THE STATE OR LOCAL
AGENCIES MUST BE ADDRESSED. AND
THE LANGUAGE MUST BE UPDATED TO
REFLECT THE PRAGMATIC REALITY
IN IMPLEMENTATION IN TERMS OF
HOW PEOPLE HAVE COMPLAINED TO
THE FACT SHE WAITED. AT THE
JURISDICTIONAL LEVEL FINALLY
ONE EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE FOR
THE TIME EXTENSION. FOR THE
APPALACHIANS PROGRAM. THE WORLD
CLASS PROGRAM THE LEGISLATURE
IS CREATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IT MUST BE DONE CORRECTLY. THE
REGULATORY PROCESS TO DATE HAS
NOT GONE SMOOTHLY AND NOT
RESULT IN IN WHAT WE CONSIDER
TO BE A WORKABLE PROGRAM THIS
TIMELINE IS NECESSARY. IN ORDER
TO GET THIS RIGHT WHEN YOU GET
TO THE GROUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MODERATOR COULD
YOU FILL ME IN ON HOW MANY ARE
LEFT IN THE QUEUE. YES WE HAVE-
TEN MORE OKAY GREAT BUT YOU CAN
PROCEED. THANKS FOR THE TIP
LINE. ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ALEX WHERE
I WANT TO PREACH TAKE TIME TO
APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORT THAT
AND IT ONLY BE. ONE FORTY ONE-
AND THANK YOU TO READ AND SHARE
MEMORIES WITH MANY FOR. LOOKING
TO COMMENT ON ALL THE INPUT
THAT YOU CAN GET N A CAR WITH
A BROAD COALITION. OF
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS- THAT. ARE
MOSTLY IN THE COURT OF WHERE WE
GOT WITH EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE I
THINK. THERE'S A BIT OF
SPECTRUM WHEN IT COMES TO THE
END DATE BUT- STEPPING BACK AND
LOOKING AT THE INTENT OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR. FIVE YEARS AGO
VOTERS CLEARLY INTENDED TO BE
STRICTLY VINYL COMPLIANCE. WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. AND
REGULATIONS. INTERNAL QUALITY
ACTING CALIFORNIANS INTERNAL
REGULATIONS. THAT INSURERS
THERE'S REVIEW BEGIN TOMORROW
IMPACTED BOTH MEDICATION
MEASURES. AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROVISIONS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE SALE. TO ENSURE
THERE IS MOVEMENT THE DENTAL
PROGRESS WITH THAT PEOPLE
COMPLAINED- I'D LIKE PEOPLE
THERE IS NO DOCTOR CAN ACQUIRE
THE ALGAE EARLIER- BUILDING
AIRPLANE WATER ON IT. THE CARD
ARE THE SEAT BELTS AND WE NEED
TO BE SURE THEY'RE PART OF THAT
PACKAGE- AS AS WE'RE BUILDING
THIS. PROGRAM AND- I THINK WHAT
LIKE A SAID ALL GROUPS. BECAUSE
THE SPEAKER MEASURE ADAMS. WE
ALL WE'RE NOT IN COMPLETE
AGREEMENT ABOUT THAT EXTENSION
TO TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THE
GROUP'S THURSDAY NEUTRON THAT
BECAUSE THEY FIND TWENTY TWENTY
SIX B. I'M I'M REALLY LONG TIME
LINE AT TEN YEARS AFTER
PROPERTY PEOPLE OVER THE PAST-
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE FULL
INTERNAL. WITH THE POINT OF A
RAG. AND COUPLE GROUPS YOUR
SENIOR TROLL THE RESTAURANT THE
PORRIDGE. WELCOME TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
LOCAL PROGRAMS IN HOPES WE CAN
REALLY ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE TAKING SO
LONG TO DATE. WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
ATLANTA- LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRE
RECORDS REALLY ARE- UM AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. AND TRYING TO FIND
AN AGREEMENT ON THE SEPARATE-
THREE AFTER. I FELT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. LET'S GO
TO LINE. TWO FIFTY FIVE. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON YES THANK YOU
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THIS IS LAURIE
CAMERAS- WITH NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS NOT- CALIFORNIA AND
SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA. I AM
CALLING YOU REGARDING CONCERNS
THAT- FIFTEEN ASSOCIATION TO
REPRESENT SMALL BUSINESS AND
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO HAVE SENT
LETTERS THAT ARE ON FILE WITH
THE COMMITTEE- ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE. WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD THAT YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND IS A
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM- IF THE GRANT PROGRAM
FOR START UP COMPANIES ONLY WE
HAVE THE SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
AND WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS-
ETCETERA THAT ARE HELPING
EXISTING BUSINESSES MICRO
BUSINESSES AND START UP
COMPANIES WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THE FUNDING FOR THE DREAM FIND
ONLY APPLIES TO STARTUPS AND
THAT THERE IS NOT ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO MAINTAIN THE PROGRAM
THAT THE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS ARE DOING-
THE PROGRAMS THAT- THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING SO WELL
ESPECIALLY HELPING. SMALL
BUSINESSES AND MICRO BUSINESSES
NAVIGATE DURING PANDEMIC AND
NOW IN IN THAT RECOVERY DOREEN-
AS YOU KNOW POST PANDEMIC TIME
SO WE URGE YOU TO REVIEW THE
FINDINGS IN THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FIND OUT WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
CALIFORNIA TAKE PROGRAMS SHOULD
BE SEPARATE PROGRAM IT'S REALLY
STANDING ON ITS OWN- WE'D LIKE
TO SEE IT CONTINUE TO WRITE
FIVE YEAR TEN YEAR AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE- SMALL BUSINESSES
WHO HAPPENS SIR TO CONTINUE TO
BE SERVED AND THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE. ADEQUATELY FUNDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN THE
TANK AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION THE INTERNATIONAL
CANADA FARMERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE COOKBOOK GROWTH OF FIFTY
SEVEN I'M REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE
AROUND THE CONSOLIDATION OF THE
THREE LICENSING AND FEES AS
WELL AS THE OPERATING LANGUAGE
TO ALLOW FOR CABOT STREET
SAMPLE- BUT WE DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
PROVISIONS. HAVING SAID THAT I
DO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MADE
BY SENATOR CAFIERO WELL AND
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING IN FURTHER
DISCUSSION AS WE SHAPE THE
CLEANUP- THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
AS PROPOSED- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT- I AM A BIT CONCERNED-
THAT THERE WAS NO MENTION OF
ANY POTENTIAL CHANGES AROUND
THE SHORTENED TIMELINE. FOR
EXISTING PROVISIONAL LICENCE
HOLDER CULTIVATING ACCESS OF
ONE ACRE BORN AFTER THE TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT CANOPY
AND WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE RANDY
MARTIN- THIS XCELERATED
TIMELINE FOR THESE OPERATORS
WILL LIKELY RESULT IN THE
CLOSURE OF A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF CULTIVATION OPERATIONS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT WERE
ALREADY APPROVED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND ISSUED A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE THANK YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO- WORKING
THROUGH ALL THE ISSUES AND
APPRECIATE. THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE THAT FAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE TYLER TO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
SHOP. LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI WHOSE NATURE RIGHT THE
NEW YEARS FOR THIRTY MINUTES
CALIFORNIA MICRO BUSINESS BUT.
NINETEEN REALLY FRANCE PROGRAM.
FINDING WILL HOLD- THANK YOU
PLANNERS AND BUSINESSES IN OUR
ANDERSON UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN MINUTES. THANK
YOU. MEXICO TO LINE TWO FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINES OPEN. I
MOVED ON TO LINE TO SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GREETING-
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE KARATE AND I AM THE
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER FOR
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS REGULATION. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE TO ATTENTION TODAY LIKE
MANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DVR AS MANY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL. IN A LICENSURE HAD BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE A NECESSARY.
THREE PROGRAMS ARE MORE
RESPONSIBLE AND EQUITABLE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. DEVELOPMENT
ISSUED APPROXIMATELY A THOUSAND
TEMPORARY APPROVALS OR LOCAL
TEMPORARY LICENSES TO CANNABIS
BUSINESS CENTER NONE OF THESE
DIFFERENCES. PLACES UNDER THE
CITY'S LAW ONLY SOCIAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS CAN APPLY FOR RETAIL
DELIVERY OR CULTIVATION
LICENSES UNTIL JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. HUNDRED OF
THE EXISTING APPLICANTS MANY OF
WHICH ARE PARTICIPANTS IN THE
CITY SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAM. MAY
NOT MEET THE REQUIREMENTS TO
RECEIVE STATE PROVISIONAL
LICENSE BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY. TWO FURTHERMORE
WITHOUT AN EXTENSION OF THE
ISSUANCE OF STATE PROVISIONALLY
BEYOND YOUR JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HUNDREDS OF
NEW LOCAL EQUITY APPLICANTS
WON'T GET THE BENEFIT OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSE OR
LICENSURE. AND WON'T BE ABLE TO
OPERATE AND MAINTAIN A STATE
AND LICENSING. DEALS DELAYED
KIND OF SIGNIFICANT COST
ENTREPRENEURS SPECIFICALLY OUR
SOCIAL EQUITY APPLICANTS. THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES- IS DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE NEWLY
DEVELOPED LOCAL JURISDICTION
GRANT PROGRAM TO ADDRESS WE
NEED TO TRANSITION PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES. INTERSTATE ANNUAL
LICENSING PROGRAM WITH THIS IN
MIND THOUGH BOTH OF OUR
APPLICANTS. AND ENGAGE YOUR-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEXICO TO
TWO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CROSSWORD ON BEHALF
OF THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY GROWERS
ALLIANCE- WANTED TO COMMENT ON
EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE- FIRST ONE
TO SAY THAT WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF AN APPRECIATIVE
OF. THE TREATABLE PROVISIONS
WHICH ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
LEGISLATION. YOU ARE- THE
CONTEMPLATION AND FRAMEWORK FOR
PATHWAY FOR SMALL AND
INDEPENDENT CULTIVATION
BUSINESSES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACT QUICKLY AFTER STRAIGHT
SAMPLES AND TO BE ABLE TO
MARKET THEIR OWN. PRODUCTS TO
RETAILERS IN PLACES LIKE LOS
ANGELES IN THE BAY AREA. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
REGULATORS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE PROVISIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTED- WITHIN REGULATIONS
MET. HALFWAY FOR SMALL
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES AND- WE
ALSO WANTED TO ECHO SENATOR
REQUIRES COMMENTS- REGARDING
THE APPALACHIANS PROGRAM.
SUPPORTED BY THE EXTENSION OF
THE DEFERRED THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT PROGRAM TO JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THOUSAND WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S-
ESSENTIAL THAT THAT PROGRAM BE
IMPLEMENTED WITH THE UTMOST
INTEGRITY- AND BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S STILL MORE WORK TO DO.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE- PUT IN PLACE
IN A WAY THAT IF THE WHOLE- IT
ALSO DID- THERE'S A
CONSIDERATION WITH THE NEW
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL-
DATE- EVERYTHING IS SORT OF
LINED. UP BEFORE THAT PROGRAM
GOES INTO EFFECT. I WHEN IT
COMES TO PROVIDE I CAN- WE ARE.
THE KIND. OCCURRED ON
PROVISIONAL LICENSES- THE
FLIGHT THIS BILL AND WE DO
THINK THAT THERE'S MORE WORK TO
BE DONE. IN PARTICULAR WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BENCHMARKS AROUND PEOPLE
COMPLIANCE IMMIGRANT FORWARD
ARE APPROPRIATE AND ATTAINABLE-
FOR SMALL CULTIVATORS AND MIKE
AND THESE. ARE OUR OFFICE
SUPPLY CHAIN- AND WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE WAY IN
WHICH THESE PROVISIONS THE
BENCHMARK A WRITTEN.
INTERPRETERS RECIPROCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY UNDERSTANDING
THAT LIFE AND DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MOVE FORWARD
AND GET PAID FOR COMPLIANCE.
BUT ALSO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND STATE REGULATORS ARE PART
OF THE SITUATION AS WELL. AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS ARE INCLUDED IN
THAT CONVERSATION. YOU LOOK FOR
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
LANGUAGE AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK. THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
BILL SO FAR THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO LINES OPEN. NOT TO LINE TO
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. COMBINED
GREETINGS MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
THE MALACHI A MAN. OF THE
CALIFORNIA URBAN PARTNERSHIP
AND- THE CALIFORNIA URBAN
PARTNERSHIPS FANS AND
SUPPORTERS OF AB ONE FORTY ONE
IF IT IS AMENDED THERE ARE.
SOME GOOD PARTS ABOUT EIGHTY
ONE FORTY ONE BUT THERE ARE
SEVERE DEFICIENCIES WHEN IT
COMES TO. CULTURAL COMPETENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO EQUITY AND
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS INDUSTRY
BEING REGULATED AND A TRAUMA
INFORMED WAY. AND SO WE'RE
URGING THE COMMITTEE TO NOT
IGNORE ENTREPRENEURS WHO ARE
SURVIVORS OF CALIFORNIA'S
RACIALIZED ENFORCEMENT OF
MARIJUANA POLICY. SIMPLY ADDING
A COMMONLY USED DEFINITION. FOR
SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESS. IT WILL
BE ABLE TO THE ABUSE OF FUNDING
THAT IT HAS ALREADY ALLOCATED
FOR HELP REAL DRUG WAR
SURVIVORS ENTER A VERY COSTLY
AND COMPLEX CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
BIG WIDE SOCIAL EQUITY
DEFINITION WILL HELP THE STATE
AND PROVIDING EVALUATION
CRITERIA FOR THE DISTRIBUTION
OF EQUITY GRANT FUNDING GOING
FORWARD. AS WELL AS TO THE
VALUE WAIT WHAT CONSTITUTES A
BONA FIDE SOCIAL EQUITY
BUSINESS IN THE STATE LICENSING
PROFIT. CALIFORNIA IS NOW
BOASTING ABOUT SPENDING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSING BACKLOG PROBLEMS THAT
WE MOSTLY BENEFITS SOCIAL
EQUITY BUSINESSES. PROBLEM IS
THAT THE STATE DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE A CLEAR DEFINITION. FOR
WHAT IF SOCIAL EQUITY BUSINESS
IS AND THE JOB OF FIXING A
STATE LICENSE PROBLEM IT'S NOT
A JOB BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MY
TO GO THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
EQUITY ALLIANCE SUBMITTED
LANGUAGE FOR A STATE WIDE
SOCIAL EQUITY DEFINITIONS. TO
LEADERSHIP AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND FINALLY WE'RE JUST URGING
THAT YOU USE THAT LANGUAGE IN
EIGHTY ONE FORTY ONE. AND A
THREE YEAR DELAY OF CANNABIS
EQUITY IN CALIFORNIA AND TO
ENSURE THAT ECONOMIC JOB.
BECOMES A REALITY THANK YOU.
MODERATOR ARE WE- CONCLUDED
BECAUSE WE'RE ABOUT TO RUN OUT
OF TIME FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
HOW MANY ARE THERE FINALLY Q.
HOW MANY. FIVE FIVE OKAY SO
PEOPLE ADDED ALL RIGHT WE- WHAT
I NEED TO ASK THOSE IN THE
QUEUE NOW SINCE WE ARE. OUT OF
THE TIME FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
I'M NOT ALLOW YOU TO PROCEED
BUT I WOULD PREFER FOR IT I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TRY
TO BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE TRY
TO GET YOUR COMMENTS IN IN
THIRTY SECONDS. THANK YOU.
PROCEED. I AM GOING OUT TO LINE
TO SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON EIGHTY
ONE FORTY ONE PERSON JUST WANNA
SAY WE SUPPORT THE PROVISIONS
AND CONSOLIDATING THE THREE
LICENSING AGENCIES INTO ANY
DEPARTMENT. WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE LANGUAGE AROUND
CANADA'S PROVISIONAL LICENSES
SPECIFICALLY AROUND TIME LINE
AND THE NEED TO ENSURE FULL
RANGE OF COMPLIANCE MECHANISMS
UTILIZED BY THE AGENCIES TO
MEET PEOPLE OBLIGATION FOR
CANNABIS. AND INCLUDED LASTLY
THIS WEDNESDAY WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK DONE SO FAR THE
COMMENTS MADE BY SENATORS HOBBY
ERR ON THE CHOIR AND DOLLY I
MEAN MINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATORS WILLINGNESS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND CLEANUP
LANGUAGE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE DISCUSSIONS. ON THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
NINA PARKS I'M UPDATING THE
EQUITY TRADE CERTIFICATION. I
WILL WHILE AD BUT- THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY
ALLIANCE- COMMENTING ON IT
EIGHTEEN ONE FORTY ONE I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES- MALEK AND
MALACHI HAD DONE SUCH A GREAT
JOB AT OUTLINING EXACTLY WHAT
THE PROBLEMS ARE. AS WELL IS
THAT WHAT THE MARKET FOR DARK-
YES AND PRESS ON YOU GUYS THAT
THE TIMELINE TO CREATE AN
UNNECESSARY EXTINCTION EVENT
WHICH COMPOUNDS TRAUMAS FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE READY-
HEALING FROM I'M JEFF.
INTERACTION WITH THE POLICE
WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS IN ORDER
TO PLEASE WRAP UP YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU. OKAY SO IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO PREVENT THESE THINGS
FROM HAPPENING CAN YOU PLEASE
JUST. TAKE A LOOK AT THE
TIMELINE. TO MAKE THEM FOR. SO
WHERE ARE THE BY IN IN LINE
WITH FROM A TANDEM IN ACTUALLY
GETTING THINGS IMPLEMENTED IN A
IN A REALISTIC MANNER. THANK
YOU SATURDAY. THANKS TO THE TO
LINE TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE GLOBAL PHARMA. I
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN AND
IF YOU'RE CALLING ON THE CANVAS
EQUITY COULD YOU JUST PLEASE
SAY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND-
YOUR SUPPORT OR NON SUPPORT. GO
AHEAD. PROCEED PLEASE. RIGHT ON
THE LINE TWO SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL CAN TELL
EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRAINED IN RELATION TO THE
CROSS OR ST BUT I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR INDUSTRY'S PROFOUND
GRATITUDE TO LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND YOUR
RESPECTIVE STAFF. OR DANCING
THE VERY FASTER RELIEF AND
FLEXIBILITY MEASURES FOR PUBLIC
TRANSIT INCLUDING EIGHTY ONE
FORTY NINE THE TRANSPORTATION
CURLY BILL YEAH THAT TIME IS
SHORT THOUGH THANK YOU AGAIN
APPRECIATE- THE STRONG SHOW OF
SUPPORT FOR INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR. TO GO TO
LINE TWO FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JENNIFER FEARING HERE
TO EXPRESS GRATITUDE AND
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION AND
THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE
FEDERATION FILLING THE
CONSTRUCTION ONE OF THE FAMILY
THOUGH ONE FORTY NINE GRANTING
AUTHORITY TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD TO CONSIDER
AND APPROVE MEANING OF NON
VEHICULAR WHILE LIKE CROSSING.
HEALTHCARE PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS TO ENSURE
INVESTMENT IN KEY CONSERVATION
PROJECTS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THE RECOVERED HEAT WILDLIFE
SPECIES THAT ARE UNDER EVER
INCREASING PRESSURE WE WENT TO
PHYSICALLY THANK SENATOR
STARTING GONZALES AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WOMEN. THREE MEN FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE TWO SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE PLAN. ONE TWO
THREE THREE LINES OPEN. MY
MODERATOR NEXT. JUST ONE MOMENT.
AND THS SHOULD BE THE LAST ONE
SINCE YOU INDICATED FIVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE RUN OUT OF TIME.
THIS IS THE LAST ONE THANK YOU.
THIRTY NINE TO FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET ME SHARE
ROBERT TERRORISTS ON THE APP
OKAY HEY ARE YOU IN CALIFORNIA
ONE TERMINUS THANK YOU FOR A.
B. ONE THIRTY SIX AND- THE
EQUITY PROVISIONS THAT WE-
FINALLY QUIT INDIAN PERFORMANCE
PROVISIONS AND BLAMED THE
DEFEAT. FORT BOTTLED UP RIGHT.
THE PAPERS ON THE FLOOR- ALSO
IN REGARD TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY
ONE STEPPED UP AS HE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA JOINED OUR LABOR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS BOARDING
THAT FACT NOW HAVE A CLEAR PATH
WE ARE FOR A VIRAL COMPLIANCE
YEAH THE FUNDING TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN. AND WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE ATHLETES ARE PROVISIONS
WHERE HE WENT AND THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE GOING NOW FINDING
MECHANISM BUT I THINK THE CORE.
LINES WITH YOUR ACTING YOU
CAN'T. DELAYED MONEY FOR EQUITY
INCOME YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE-
WHAT DOES LEBANON THROUGH.
DEFINITION THANK GOD I'M HERE
NINE MONTHS THANK YOU MR. BY
MODERATOR BELIEVE THAT WAS OUR
LAST CALLER ON. PRECIADO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND NOW WE WILL
ENTERTAIN MOTIONS ON THESE
TRAILER BILLS AND VICE CHAIR
DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT YOU WANT
TO MAKE BEFORE ENTERTAINING
EMOTIONS. OKAY THEN LET'S SEE
THERE'S A MOTION ON AB ONE
THIRTY FOUR MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED THIS IS THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT- MR
STEPPING CHART PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FOUR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER. SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
NELSON HI COPYRIGHT. HI CORTESE
DOLLY ALI HI THE RISER. TORONTO
HI ADNAN FIGMENT HIGH GROWTH.
COM LONGER. LEHRER THERE HI
MCGUIRE. MELINDA'S MAN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE.
PENN PAN HI STERN STERN ALRIGHT
WAKE COUNTY BY COUNTY HI. WE
WILL HOLD THAT BILL AND CALL ON
WE HAVE NOW MOVED TO EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY SIX THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED- MR STEP IN SHOCK. YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SCANNER BY
SKINNER HI NIELSEN. NELSON HI
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE
DOLLY DOLLY HI TORONTO. TORONTO
HI EGGMAN. HEY MAN HIGH GROWTH
COM LONGER LAYERED. HI MCGUIRE.
MELINDA'S MAN MAN HI NIMIN.
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE TROUBLE
HI PEN PEN HI STERN. STERN HI
KELSEA MY CASKEY HI I WILL ALSO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT ONE
WE'LL GO TO EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MOVED BY SENATOR LAYERED.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN RIGHT I DID ONE
THIRTY SIX NELSON THREE EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY SEVEN MOST OF THE
PAST SENATOR SKINNER HI THERE
HI. NIELSEN NIELSEN HI
COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE.
DOLLY ALI NO THE RAZA. RAZA HI
ADNAN A MINUTE HIGH GROWTH COM
OTHER. LAYERED. HI MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MAN MAIN ARGUMENT.
NEWMAN HI- TROUBLE. TROUBLE HI
PAM PAN HI STERN. STERN HI WHY
CASKEY WORKOUTS SKI HIGH GROWTH.
GROVE HI. RIGHT WILL ALSO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN ON A. B. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN SO LET'S MOVE TO
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT THE
EMPLOYMENT HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS- MOVED BY SENATORS.
LAYERED. AB ONE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER. HI SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. NELSON HI COVER GIRL
COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE DOLLY ALI
NO DIRAJA TORONTO HI EGGMAN
SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH. GROVE NOT
LOADING COMMA LONGER. LAYERED
LEHRER HI MCGUIRE LINDA S. MEN.
MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI THE
TROUBLE TROUBLED I. TEN N. HI
STERN EASTERN HI WHITE COUNTY.
WHY CASKEY HI. CAMARGO HI. OKAY
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN AND
WE'LL GO TO AB ONE FORTY NINE I
MEAN SKEWS ME EIGHTY ONE FORTY
NINE ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROLLED MOVED BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI. WHAT
DID I SAY ONE FORTY ONE I SAID
I SAID ONE FORTY INE AND THEN
I CORRECTED MYSELF ONE FORTY
ONE. YES HE'S MOVING ONE FORTY
ONE MISTER WHITE CASKEY HE PUT
HIS HAND UP SO GO AHEAD MR I
CAST YOU MOVED IT LET'S HEAR
THE ROLL CALL. EIGHTY ONE FORTY
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATOR SKINNER BY SKINNER HI.
NIELSEN COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT I
VOTING CORTESE. DOLLY DAWALY
NOT VOTING TO RAZA. ROGER HI
ADNAN. SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH GROW
HI FROM OTHER CAMARGO HI
LAYERED. LEHRER HI MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MAN IN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI- TROUBLE. JOE VOTE
NOT VOTING PENN FAN HI STERN.
STERN HI WHERE CASKEY CASKEY HI
RIGHT WE WILL LEAVE A B. ONE
FORTY ONE OPEN NOW LET'S MOVE
TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY THREE
SENATOR LAYERED HAS MOVED IT-
ROLL CALL PLEASE EIGHTY ONE
FORTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS SENATORS SKINNER BY
SKINNER HI. NIELSEN NIELSEN HI
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT HI COURTESY.
DALI DALI HI RAZA RAZA HI ADNAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. GROVE HI
COME AUGUST. CAMARGO BY LAYERED
THEIR TIME ACQUIRE WIRE HI
MELINDA IS MAN MAN HI NEWMAN.
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE. THE
TROUBLE HI. IN PM HI STERN.
STERN HI WHAT KIND OF KEY. WHAT
KOWSKI HI ALL RIGHT WE WILL
ALSO LEAVE THAT ONE OPEN I WILL
NOW MOVE TO AB ONE FORTY FIVE
PUBLIC SAFETY MOTION BY SENATOR
LAYERED. PLEASE ROLL CALL
EIGHTY ONE FORTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
YES AND NO COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
HI CORTESE DOLLY KHALID NARROW
DIRAJA BROTHER HI ADNAN.
ELEMENT HI GROWTH GROVE NO
LONGER HELLO- I LAYERED. LEHRER
I REQUIRE. BRIAR HI MELINDA'S
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE NO.
PENN TEN HI STERN. STERN HI
WHAT COUNTS BE BY KATHY HI. DID
WE HAVE ANY MISSING MEMBERS ON
THAT ONE. I DON'T THINK WE HAD
ANY MISSING MEMBERS CORRECT.
FOLLOW SORRY POLICY SO WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN ON THAT
OKAY SO WE'LL GO TO A B. ONE
FORTY NINE MOVED BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY WELL MISTER DALI I'LL
GET YOU NEXT- EIGHTY ONE FORTY
NINE TRANSPORTATION ROLL CALL
PLEASE. EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE
THE MOTION IS DUE PAST SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NILSSON.
NILSSON HI COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT
HI CORTESE. DOLLY DOLLY HI RAZA
RUSSELL HI ADNAN. EGGMAN EGGMAN
SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH GROVE HI
COME UNDER MUGGER HI LAYERED.
LEHRER HI MIKE WEIR. CHOIR HI
MELINDA IN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN
HI THE TROUBLE WITH. THE
TROUBLE HI IN. PM HI STERN.
STERN HI WHAT KIND OF SKI.
CASKEY HI. ALL RIGHT- WE WILL
ALSO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE WILL GO
TO A B. ONE FIFTY SALES AND USE
TAX LAW BUT SENATOR DOLLY MOVES.
IT AB ONE FIFTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS SENATORS SCANNER BY
SKINNER HI. NILSSON NILSSON HI
COPYRIGHT. HI COURTESY DALI
DALI HI THE RISER. THE BROWSER
HI ADNAN EGMOND HIGH GROWTH
GROWTH HI TOM UNGER. IN ORDER
HI LAYERED LATER I'M ACQUIRE.
CHOIR HI MELINDA'S. MAN MEN
HEIGHT NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI-
TROUBLE. GLOBAL HI PAN. IN HI
STERN. STERN I WORK BY COUNTY
HI ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW WE'LL
LEAVE AT ONE FIFTY OPEN MAYBE
ONE FIFTY ONE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED. EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER HI BEGINNER HI NIELSEN.
NELSON HI COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
HI CORTESE DOLLY. DOURADO DRAGO
HI ADNAN. FIGMENT HIGH GROWTH.
GROW NOT VOTING COM LARGER A
MOTHER HI LEHRER. LEHRER HI
MCGUIRE. CHOIR ALL RIGHT MAN.
MANNHEIM NEWMAN. HI THE TROUBLE.
TROUBLE HI IN. HI STERN. STERN
HI WHAT COUNTY WHAT COUNTY ARE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN ON A. B. ONE FIFTY ONE NOW
THE LAST EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
CRIME PREVENTION MOVED BY
SENATOR LAYERED ROLL CALL
PLEASE. EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER BY SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
YES AND NO COPYRIGHT ZERO HI
CORTESE DOLLY CHARLIE NELL.
DORADO BROWSER HI HEY MAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. GROWTH NO
LONGER CAMARGO HI LAYERED LATER
HI WIRE. CHOIR I'M LINDA THIS.
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE. TROUBLED NOW IN
FAN HI STERN. STERN HI BY CAL
SKI MICHALSKI HI ALL RIGHT
SINCE OUR MEMBER- HAS RETURNED
WHY DON'T WE RE OPEN THE ROLES
ON AB ONE THIRTY FOUR AND YOU
CAN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY OKAY. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS. TO PASS
SENATORS CORTESE ORDERLY HI.
WITH GROWTH. THIS IS A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AB ONE
THIRTY FOUR. GROVE HI CONLOGUE
FROM MARGARET HI. MELINDA'S THE
TROUBLE JO'BURG HI. MCGUIRE HI
WIRE HI THERE. SO THAT BILL IS
OUT WITH SIXTEEN VOTES CORRECT
SEVENTEEN VOTES OKAY. BUT I
THINK IT'S SIXTEEN WE HAD A
MISSING MEMBER. YEAH LIVE THE
YES MOVEMENT IS MISSING SO AS
NOT MAKE. WELL YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU'RE RIGHT APOLOGIES MIGHT
BITE WAS NOT TELLING CORRECTLY
SO EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FOURS OUT
WITH SEVENTEEN VOTES LET'S GO
TO EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX LET'S
CALL THE OPPOSITE MEMBERS.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR IS
CRITICIZING. WHAT IS THE HI.
GROWTH COMMA- COM AUGER HI
BLEIER. ENQUIRE HI MELINDA S.
BUT A. B. ONE THIRTY SIX IS OUT
WITH SIXTEEN VOTES. YES OKAY
WE'LL GO TO A B. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AP ONE THIRTY SEVEN
MOTION WAS TO PASS. SENATORS
CORTESE CORTESE HI. COM LOGGER.
COM AUGER HI. ENQUIRE ENQUIRE
HI. SO THAT BUILDS I WAS.
SIXTEEN SIXTEEN SIXTEEN I WON
NO. ALL RIGHT SO LET'S GO TO A.
B. ONE THIRTY EIGHT- YOU WILL
LET'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT THE
MOTION WAS TO PASS SENATORS
CORTESE. CORTESE HI. MCGUIRE
WHERE HI MELINDA S. THAT'S
FIFTEEN ARISE WHEN NO. THE
BILLS OUT FIFTEEN EYES WERE NO
WE'LL GO TO A B. ONE FORTY ONE
YOU CAN CALL THE OPPOSITE
MEMBERS. AB ONE FORTY ONE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. SENATORS
CORTESE CORTESE HI APPLIER.
WIRE HI MELINDA'S. I BELIEVE
THAT'S OUT WITH THIRTEEN VOTES.
THIRTEEN RICE. OKAY WE WILL NOW
GO TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY THREE.
EIGHTY ONE FORTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS CORTESE.
CORTESE HI MELINDA S. RIGHT
THAT BOAT THAT BILL ONE FORTY
THREE IS OUT SEVENTEEN VOTES. I
WILL GO TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY
FIVE AP ONE FORTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS CORTESE.
WHICH IS THE HI MELINDA S. OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT WITH THIRTEEN
AND- FOR KNOWS. RIGHT WILL GO
TO AB ONE FORTY NINE. AB ONE
FORTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CORTESE. DAISY I MELINDA'S.
RIGHT THAT BILLS OUT WITH
SEVENTEEN VOTES NOW WILL GO TO
EIGHTY ONE FIFTEEN EXCUSE ME
ONE FIVE ZERO THE SALES AND USE
TAX A. B. ONE FIVE ZERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS CORTESE
TRACEY HI MELINDA S. RIGHT THAT
BUILDS OUT ONE FIFTY WITH
SEVENTEEN VOTES. LET'S GO TO A.
B. ONE FIFTY ONE. A. B. ONE
FIFTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
RTZ CORTESE HI MELINDA S. RIGHT
THAT I MAY NOT HAVE TO KILL
CORRECT SO. I HAD FOURTEEN
FIFTY FIVE IST TO NOSE OR IS IT
FIFTEEN EYES TO NOSE FIFTEEN.
FIFTEEN ZERO EXCUSE ME ALL
RIGHT SO. EIGHTY ONE FIFTY ONE
IS OUT WITH FIFTEEN ICE. OKAY
MAYBE ONE FIFTY SEVEN. EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS CORTESE CRITICIZING HI
MELINDA S. YES THAT- EIGHTY ONE
FIFTY SEVEN IS OUT THIRTEEN ICE
FOR KNOWS. AND WITH THAT WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA FOR THE-
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE CLEARLY IF THERE WERE
ANY FOLKS WHO- IN THEIR CALL
IN. I DIDN'T HEAR THEIR PROMPT
AND WANT TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
TO US YOU CAN SUBMIT ANY
COMMENTS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THROUGH OUR
WEBSITE AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INPUT AND WITH THAT THE-
COMMITTEE ON SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW WILL
ADJOURN.